Bop, there, hello!
Hello everybody, I am alive yet again, another day of
dokeybird is alive, not mentally alive.
Physically I am present, I'm sorry for being late, guys.
I took a little nap, because my body was not used to being
awake.
during any hours.
I passed out right after the tournaments.
Well, I got, I celebrated with Hot Pot, but like right after
the tournament, the double tournament, I celebrated with Hot
Pot just because I was like, yeah!
Even like, I got last place in both tournaments.
I was like, yeah!
Let's go!
I did not...
I gave kept a trip to Orlando.
Celebration time.
Yeah.
Also, I realized, is my Twitch...
Did I even set up my Twitch?
I realized I didn't even set up my Twitch correctly.
We're not watching the Xbox showcase.
We're watching the...
Game Showcase.
We're watching...
I just realized I didn't even set up my title.
the gaming showcases.
Whoops, let me fix that.
I knew I forgot to do something.
Let me fix all of that.
Um, you're like, again, Adoki?
Watching all the Xbox showcase again?
Let me fix this real quick.
Um, it's rewind time.
There we go.
That should be it.
Let me double check.
Oh, shit, comrade.
Thank you for the two gifted subs.
Thank you.
Shally, they go 100 bitties.
I really appreciate it, guys.
All right, guys, I'm just fixing my title.
Yeah, round two, electric boogaloo.
What do I guess?
Would I consider it special events or chatting?
I mean, every dokey stream is a special event.
um especially when she's on time but she was not on time
ninja thank you for the 150s thank you thank you but yes i
celebrated uh my one you know it's like that that meme with
the champagne the guy popping the champagne and then he was
like and he's like yeah yeah and he was like it's like third
place but like i'm different i'm last place, but I got my
one!
Yeah!
I got my one!
Hey, Shane, thank you for the two, thank you for the two
souls, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I beat the top player in my tier, which means I beat
everybody by default.
Not even on the podium.
Brock, thank you for the Twitch Prophet.
Thank you, thank you.
I got my one!
No one thought I would.
No one thought I would beat the Viper, but I've got my one.
I don't know if you guys remember this while we were like,
while I was like doing my Viper, like my Alex slash Viper
gauntlet.
And then Faisy was just like, you don't, you shouldn't be.
Like she was watching the Coney versus Ricky matchup.
And she, I don't know if you guys heard what she was saying,
but she was like, like, I'm so sorry, Duke, you don't
deserve to be in this deer.
You're so fucked.
And I was just like, I was like, I know, I don't know how
are you beating these.
I just, I, I was like, harsh, but very true.
But I beat him.
I beat him.
Nobody expects the coughing pain.
to have a knife but I did it I did it guys so so I went to
hot pot I went to hot pot to celebrate the last place
celebration um and you know I knew what I knew what I
expected going in like I said I knew I was the worst player
in my tier because it didn't help that I keep starting new
characters every time I do this tournament I just fucking
fucking let's relearn everything from scratch and also like
every time the tournament's over I don't touch Street
Fighter or like a fighting game again until
I don't touch fighting games until I get invited to the next
fighting game tournament so I'm not a very consistent
fighting game player yeah until like one year later one year
one year later um it just makes me so angry like fighting
games make me so angry in general I don't I don't know it
like it like sets off the demons inside me um um anyway what
was I saying oh yeah but yeah passed out right after hot pot
um and um and i woke up at a decent i woke up at 11 like i
actually slept a normal na hour uh which was like around i
think i went to bed at around midnight or some shit i went
to bed around midnight or 1 a.m woke up around 11 a.m and um
and i was just like you I was like, oh my God, I'm awake at
an, I'm awake at an NA time, you know, but my body didn't
catch up with that, like, my body was not ready for this
adjustment yet, because throughout the last two weeks since
I, I don't know, throughout the last week and a half since I
came back from Korea, I've been like, sleeping at God awful
times as if my body was still in Korea.
And my body was still there.
And I haven't had a real sleeping schedule in a long time.
So my body at, I think when it was at four, I think it was
like, oh no, when it was like at 3, 3.30ish PM, my body was
shutting down.
I think that's the way I can say it.
My body was shutting down.
It was just like, it was not ready.
such a so it's such a drastic transition between schedules
so I was like I have to lie down I was just like oh my god I
have to lie down I need a nap right now I really need a nap
so um and so that's why I woke up around 450 I was I said a
lot about 440 but I was just like I can't do this like I
maybe a little maybe 10 more minutes maybe 10 more minutes i
need 10 more minutes in the into this body and obviously i
was still not feeling it out just pop up for this please i
was still not feeling it guys i will have to be a minute i
my body was still not feeling it so that's why i was a
little late guys i was still trying to transition back into
a normal sleep schedule uh but yes watching all the gaming
showcases that I missed out um because uh like you guys
didn't know I was in Korea when they decided to release
everything all at once even though you know we love watching
these showcases um I was in Korea so uh I missed out on all
of them and I was supposed to watch all of them last week
but then I my body was breaking down last I don't oh yeah I
had so much stuff to I'll do it this week because I have
time.
And this is more, it's like post-tournament, post-tournament
clarity.
So, it's not actually, I'm not actually streaming or doing
anything.
We're just doing a watch a lot.
We're just reacting.
So, it's not really much work, you know?
Like, I was just like, oh man, what do I do right after the
tournament?
Because originally, I was planning on doing James Bond right
after the tournament.
And I was just like, I really don't want to play video games
right now.
I'm so tired.
Mentally and physically, I am so tired after doing two
tournaments back to back.
Like, I realized, I was like, I can't believe I was alive.
I had that much energy with only three hours of sleep.
I forgot about that part.
Like, the adrenaline hit me hard during the two tournaments.
That, like, my body did not realize that, like, it was
running on pure adrenaline.
And so the moment, because even during Hoppot, I was like,
yeah!
Woo!
Even right after a tournament, Hoppot's like, yeah!
Got my one!
Wow!
And then I got home, and then I passed out in the bed.
Sean, thank you for the 450s.
Thank you, thank you.
John, thank you for gifting I'm gifting a song.
I'm beating a diamond player.
Let's take a go.
Go.
Thank you for the hundred biddies.
Thank you.
If you are thinking for the hundred biddies.
Um, yeah.
Uh, what else I wanted to say?
Um, uh, oh yeah.
Coney finally messaged me back because I sent him another
message being like, yeah, I beat the Viper play.
I beat the, I wrote to him.
I beat the Viper.
Viper who beats you in the end so it's like I won and I sent
him that I didn't want to retweet it because I I it was so I
thought it was a very funny meme but someone made a meme of
like Kony and I in a bus and I'm like at Overwatch and then
Kony was stuck in Street Fighter because apparently the the
the tournament went on for a long time and apparently he was
he looked really miserable because he was so tired yeah he
was so tired by the end and he still got second place he
like yes yes he he worked so hard and yet he's so in the end
he only got second place and then i sent him that meme for
those who didn't see it i literally i sent him this meme at
the end i didn't want retweet it like straight after it
because i am i didn't want to like like i don't know i felt
like it looked weird if i retweeted it right after because
like it is the capcom official event so i'm like i'm just
gonna sound like i'm just gonna put a couple buffered
because i thought it was funny i thought it was funny um and
then coney was like la ma wait you beat that guy and then
he's like dude i was so fucking mad when i saw you playing
overwatch i said yes to the event but canceled because i
said yes to street fighter months ago and then i saw you in
it and was like man
i was like yeah you and i i replied back i was just like bro
you could have done both the tournament ended an hour before
street fighter
He could have been in both.
Sorry, Kony.
They didn't shift.
Yeah, I mean, they pushed the Street Fighter time.
Like, it was supposed to start at 4 for Street Fighter.
But then they did it to 12.
And I asked again, like, hey, I do have this other
tournament.
Are we still doing 12 or 4?
Because I had to cancel it in the Overwatch tournament.
I just want to be sure.
And then they're like, oh, we're still discussing the time.
We'll let you know later on.
And then it ended up being at four.
So I was like, oh, I could do both.
They're like, yeah.
Guy, what is it?
Guy, thank you for the tier one sub.
For 15 months around.
Thank you.
Sean, thank you for the 100 bitties.
Yeah.
So I thought that was really funny.
What else?
What else is there?
Oh, yeah.
And while all of this was happening, I don't know if you
guys remember the stream, but I was making fun of how, like,
you know...
Oh, I wasn't making...
Okay, maybe I was.
But do you guys know how Canada apparently won their very
first FIFA game ever yesterday?
I was like, oh my god, we're all... Like, it's Canada day.
Like, all the Canadians are winning today, like yesterday.
Yeah, so I don't know if you guys know this.
but Canada has never won a single match.
Oh, sorry, World Cup.
Sorry, World Cup.
Has never won a single match in World Cup before.
So it has never been a thing.
And yesterday, they finally won their first game ever.
It's like, it's crazy.
We never got past the qualifying stages.
There is a chance that there, there is a chance for the
first, not only are we going to win our very first game
ever, but, but also our very first chance at making it past
the qualifying stages, we're actually going to make it out
of groups for the first time.
ever it's all decided with our game against Switzerland um I
did not care at first because like I was given an
opportunity well I was giving the opportunity but like I
thought of I gave myself the opportunity think about whether
or not I should watch uh the World Cup because I could I
could technically like travel there to like watch it and
then I was like it's Canada like We're not gonna And I was
like I thought about it And I was like It's Canada Like I
don't want to watch my team lose Like
It's the real I thought about it No you don't understand You
don't understand Like I don't know you guys know this But
Apparently Um Um, there were no, like, you can buy tickets
so easily for the Canadian games because, um, because no
one, not a lot of people believed because we've had such a
bad history.
It's actually a really bad problem because there were, there
were like news reports about it and like the mayor had to
make a statement and everything.
and um and basically the thing was like hotel like hotels
they were giving away free tickets like some of the
participating countries that were in the i think uh that
were in like the facilities for the cat like the canada
games they had to give away tickets for free because they're
like because like no one was going like there was so many
seats like there were so many seats um um available and then
there were hotels are not fully booked by the way hotels are
not fully booked and um and like there's so many seats that
are out for like there's so many seats that you can still
buy so then i thought about it and because i was like oh the
seats aren't that expensive like i mean it's expensive
because it is world cup but you compare it to like other
prices for other country games like you compare it to like
mexico and u.s like the tickets are crazy expensive but then
if you watch like the games that where canada is playing
it's not as expensive like so like so so it was like the
demand is not that much so i was thinking about it i was
like i've never watched the world cup game before i was
thinking about it and i was like but it's canada i'm gonna
watch my like i don't am i really gonna go and watch my
country lose like Yeah, I was just thinking, I was like, am
I really gonna go to watch my country lose?
Like, yeah.
So, um, so, so, and then just to find out right after the
tournament, right after the tournament, we six owes them.
Because everybody was so surprised on Twitter.
You know what's crazy?
I saw the ticket, because I was thinking if I wanted to
watch the, I was thinking if I wanted to watch the Swiss,
because obviously I couldn't do the Qatar one.
So I was like wondering, should I watch the Canada versus
Switzerland game?
And I thought about it for a while.
I thought about it for a while.
And I looked at tickets post Canada versus, like post Canada
versus, is Qatar, tickets tripled.
The prices for tickets literally tripled right after that.
And I was just, because everyone finally started, like,
people started believing.
Like, we were like, wait a minute.
You're trying to say we actually have a chance to get, like,
this is Canadian history right now.
This is going to be Canadian history.
Like, Wait a minute.
But you said I missed my chance.
The day before Canada versus Qatar.
I made my purchase.
I, the day before Canada versus Qatar.
I bought a ticket.
I bought it.
If I sell that ticket, I could get so much money right now.
I couldn't get it so much.
If yeah, sell it.
I made, I think I, guys, guys, I could scalp it, guys.
I could, you scalp it.
Go and support just like you know.
I didn't say this story, Doki.
I thought I was like, I could triple my profits right now if
I sell it.
I'm like, what for this?
What of you lose?
Because you're not there.
My, oh, I didn't, I didn't scalp it yet, guys.
I didn't, wait, is that legal?
Is she just confessing that she's going to scalp World Cup
tickets?
Is she, they're going to find you.
FIFA's going to find you, Doki.
Uh, Jakarta, thank you for the 100 videos.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, and we know you haven't done it yet.
Uh, Gordon, thank you for the 50, 100 videos.
Thank you, thank you.
You either die a broke fan or you live long enough to become
a scalper.
So, I thought I was crazy.
I was just like, oh my God.
I was, I, I don't know I was I did not expect Canada to make
it this far guys we are making Canadian history right now I
think like a couple I think it was last was the last year
when we were joking about how like thank God thank God
Canada's an NA and we got we're like we're like the little
bro tagging along with our big bros who are so good at
soccer and then they're like you know what little bro you
can also be included in hosting the World Cup this year and
then little bros like
yeah yeah we're like oh yay but now now we have a chance
we're gonna it's the canadian soil buff also i think i
thought it was really funny because i didn't realize that
but because i was looking at tickets you know i was like
there's like you know there's venues everywhere there's
there's there's venues everywhere like around n a but like i
was like wait why are these other countries traveling to
different uh to different venues to like uh for like because
i thought you know they would stay in one venue for their
groups but kanda stays kanda stays in the same venue though
like because i was like looking i thought it was really
weird that um that like all the other um some of the other
countries have to like bounce between different um different
places yeah but like i think in u.s u.s has to travel like i
mean they still have to travel between different u.s uh
cities uh but like canada just stays in one vent like they
don't have to move anywhere like this is literally just home
advantage it's it's home advantage baby our players are not
tired at all Yeah, we need this.
We need this so badly.
We...
The NA privilege.
Yeah.
So, anyway, I might...
I may or may not.
It depends on...
It depends.
I guess how I feel next week.
If I'm gonna watch Canada versus Switzerland.
I go to Navi and don't you dare Canadian Mountain Police
notified about my OSHA scalper Oda thank you for the thank
you for the 150s thank you thank you she's gonna see if the
price goes up even more I'm gonna see if people start
getting desperate two days before she's gonna And then,
guys, she's gonna sell it one day before the game.
Any last minute buyers to be here?
No, mine's a good ticket, too, guys.
Mine's a good...
It's a good seat as well, guys.
It's a really good seat as well.
And shake my head, Doki.
That's what, no, I'm not joking.
I am not joking when I said there were so many seats
available.
It was, it was so empty.
When I looked at, when I looked at Canada versus
Switzerland, it was so empty.
I was like, I was just like, do I, do I go see Canada again?
kicked hmm and then post post guitar I think like at least
70% of the tickets were gone already I'm pretty sure I think
like 60% of tickets were gone post guitar because people
just started believing right after yeah how does she keep
getting away with these cameras yeah Post guitar Canadians
got hope and then tickets literally tripled in prices Hope
does things it really does Oh, yeah other than that I
thought it was Really funny that from the Street Fighter
tournament.
Um, I thought it was really funny
That uh It happened again where I know I tweet, because I
thought about it, so I tweeted it out where basically I lost
every game possible because it happened my very first SageM
slam.
It happened my very first SageM slam where I lost every game
possible and then I beat the best player in the tournament.
And then it happened again.
I lost every game, but I beat the best player.
but twice?
Yeah, isn't that weird?
Like, yeah, yeah, because SK beat ESAM for those who don't
remember who was a Smash Pro, like, Smash Pro player, and
she beat ESAM, and no one thought I could, yeah, no one
thought I could beat SK because obviously she was really,
she's like, literally, like, really, really good at fighting
games.
Like, she actually kept playing, became, like, a master
player.
I didn't kept playing.
um yeah isab destroyed me and then um i think if i kept
playing i definitely think i could get to masters because it
just depends on how many games you play i think i think like
fighting games is like more about the like i mean obviously
it's all about the skill but i think if i um if i just kept
playing and i just spam rank games um for like at least like
one to two months straight i think i could also get masters
um but i also like my baby elo my baby elo has less pressure
i i think i think baby elo is more fun um yeah and yeah just
the obvious yeah i need to polish my technique more and like
be more consistent and actually know what the fuck they're
doing like because my biggest i think my It's that I just
forget what their moves do.
Like CHUN-LY, because I didn't wear them out with CHUN-LY
right off the bat, so I just forgot what they can do.
So I just forget if I can block their combos.
Like, I forget their combos.
I don't know if I have to block low or medium.
So I'm just like, I don't know, it's just 50-50, let it
ride.
I think it's low.
Like, I'm just like, I think it's low.
I don't know maybe it's medium I'm doing a 50-50 it um and
so yeah so that was like my biggest problem with fighting
games I just forget like I just forget there's so many
characters how am I I don't know there's so many characters
how am I what am I gonna do what am I gonna do but anyway so
yeah I remember I beat SK no one believed that I could beat
SK in the finals like it was like a guarantee win for SK and
then I got it and then obviously like people were gambling
about it and like a lot of people lost so much money uh well
not money sorry fake money people were doing the predictions
and I think I had like what was it was I like it was a huge
upside like 15% 15% of people believed that I could win yeah
and I think like that was just out of pity or they click the
wrong thing like they they click the wrong button or like
they're just like you know I am a drag goose so you know I
guess I should like even though we I'm not gonna win this
bet I should do it as moral support like and yeah and then
um and uh yeah yeah I know Maddie you didn't vote for me I
anyway and then it happened again which is today like even
coney was surprised i beat fight the viper i beat ricky he
was like you beat the viper like you beat that guy like he
was he was equally surprised i mean we were all were like
come on don't lie we were all surprised like no one thought
it was me playing it just like how when i fought sk no one
thought it was me playing the game at that time and it was
same with sk i two-oed uh i two-oed sk and i two-oed ricky
and everyone was surprised including myself that that was
even possible i yeah yeah i was par second guys isn't
it's crazy that it happened twice guys wait you beat that
guy
so the same world matchup matchup outcome with the canadian
vtuber yeah so so in the end i was the best player in my
tier i was i deserved to be in that tier i mean i i was very
surprised that that i did win like anything like that one
rounds off uh because like i said i was the weakest player
going in and i bashed my head i didn't want to look like i'm
gonna get absolutely destroyed so the amount of hours i
committed a street fighter was it was too much like i yeah i
was it was a lot of hours so i'm glad i did something i got
something out of it uh i'm happy i got something out of it
um so yeah feisty now have the same record so technically
i'm just as good as feisty uh yeah guys uh hey kikube uh i'm
sure past okay we'll not make future oh yeah i have a
tournament next week i have technically it's one tournament
i mean it depends it depends i still can't talk about it
it's not announced but i have a tournament next week it
could be a two-day tournament it could be a one-day
tournament um it really depends on on this not i won't say
scheduling but it depends on how well my team does uh next
week um to make it to the second day uh um i'm pretty sure
let me check i don't know if they i feel like if they did
announce it i was told it was going to be announced this
week but maybe it'll be most likely it might be announced
next week i think let me double check um because my manager
was like oh can we when can we announce it and they're
saying like uh the organizer said this week when the teams
are finalized but i know the teams are finalized so i don't
know when we could talk about it uh so whenever it's
announced i do have another tournament in two weeks which is
apex because i got reached out for an apex tournament as
well next in two weeks so we also have that um so a lot of
turn this is like i feel like this month june is tournament
month i have so many tournaments lined up but it's fun i
always i'm such a competitive person so it's been fun doing
all these tournaments because uh you know i think it's a
very fun experience to meet new people um to meet people and
you know fun chemistry stuff and everything Hell month never
ends.
That's the thing, guys.
Hell month never ends.
It's hell month forever.
Every month is hell a month.
How did you find the Overwatch tournament?
Bougar just asked me.
That's really it.
Because I couldn't do the rivals tournament.
Because I was too high ranked for the last Bougar bash in
rivals.
So Bougar was like, are you down to do the Overwatch
tournament?
I was like, yeah, I'm fucking down.
Like, I haven't done an Overwatch tournament in a very long
time.
And I also helped get Chibi-Doki into the tournament as well
because Bogo was like, do you know Chibi-Doki?
Can you, like, reach out?
And I was like, yeah, of course.
And then I just like message Chibi and be like, you want to
do this?
And she's like, yeah.
And then, yeah, and then that's how she got in as well.
Yeah, he just asked me, like, do you know any VTubers who
want to be in it?
And then like, I, too bad.
I asked like other VTubers as well, but they were all busy.
I won't say who I asked but the people that I knew that used
to play Overwatch but at that time they were all like super
busy and I think like Chibi Doki was like the only person
that I knew that was free so I'm glad like Chibi had a
chance to do it as well get like you had a chance to join in
as well um all right let's actually watch the game showcase
let's go all right we're gonna start out with one first and
then peter off with this i don't i debated whether or not to
start with the smaller ones and then do the summer game fest
uh and uh and i was like fuck it let's just rip off summer
game fest first uh this is like in spirit of kyle our new
friend kyle that's crazy i didn't realize kyle was like did
like the game awards and everything and actually like knows
jeff Like, I was like, oh my, you know Jeff?
I was like, what?
Because I saw someone on Twitter mentioning about it.
And I was just like, no way.
This guy knows Jeff and has like, does stuff for the Game
Awards.
I was like, oh my God.
And he like wrote for it too.
I want to be wrote the Summer Game Fest.
Wait, he's the announcer?
He's the announcer for the Summer Game Fest slash Game, that
was so unexpected.
I did not expect it.
that at all also i don't know sound guy like tabbed out out
because sound guys been waiting sound guys been waiting for
me to do the the watch along so so sound guy please if okay
if you're here right now watching please tell me the volumes
okay in discord um oh he does the pre-show oh my god oh my
do you think he could get us tickets to the game awards
he's in he was really i mean one day on sagat uh with one
day on sagat that's the amount of progress he's he made like
i i was a little worried because uh because i was just like
i saw his like his I saw his like like the people he was
fighting and they were all like a lot higher rank than him
and it was like the day before and then I was telling I was
giving intel to shine about it and I was just like I was
like yeah um these are who he's facing and I'm a little
worried because they are they seem really good I was just
like yeah uh so his opponents are Geep, modern mind, and we
don't we just don't talk about the modern Aki who was like
that was Coffin Baby versus Hydrogen Bomb when it comes to
like the tier, the like rank, the skill different I was like
bro this guy's higher ranked than me like I was just like
hey Shad like their Aki player in their beginner tier is
higher ranked than me who is in the intermediate tier.
I was like, Shine, this guy played a thousand two hundred
plus games already, Shine.
Yeah.
I was like, Shine, we might have a little problem here.
And Shine was like, yeah, we're gonna, I'm gonna ask him to
place a god.
And I was like, what was he playing before?
And he was like, classic Manan.
And I was like, classic Manan.
and you didn't try to stop it?
You didn't...
This guy...
Kyle doesn't...
Kyle isn't a street fighter player.
You...
You let him...
You let him try and...
Try and make classic Menon?
Not...
So...
And he's like, yeah, I'm gonna see if we could...
get him to play sagat and i was like are you he has 20 and i
was like shine he has 24 hours because i because i told him
about it 24 hours uh 24 hours before the tournament and then
and then literally he had one day to prep sagat for the for
the tournament for tomorrow which was yesterday And I was
just like, oh my god!
And then Chad was like, he was like, whatever he learns in
modern sagat would be more than classic but not.
It's just like, and everything he's going to learn in a
modern sagat would be much more helpful than classic sagat.
And he was right.
He was right.
so well like he instantly jumped in elo like because like he
went from like he went like he went from bronze to silver so
fast the moment he picked up modern sagat i was and i was
like oh my god this guy if he had one more day if cal had 20
more another 24 hours i think he could beat the other
I think if he had one more, like just only one more day, he
definitely would have beat the, uh, he definitely would have
beat the other two beginners.
Not the Aki, though.
That one's hopeless.
Like, I don't even think I would have beat him.
Um, maybe I could have, because I fought a lot.
Oh, no, actually, I don't even know.
I don't know.
I do not see a lot of Aki.
I do not see a lot of Aki's during my rank grind.
Uh, I don't know.
I don't know.
I could have beat.
I don't know, honestly.
I mean, I have experience fighting Aki's from last
tournament, but I don't know.
Oh yeah, give me a sec.
Okay, I need to order something on Amazon.
Give me a sec.
One of my friends just did an SOS on me and was like, Can
you please order this on Amazon for me?
I'll pay you back, like, and have it shipped over to their
place.
I was like, sure, bro.
He was like, please, I can't do it right now.
She's selling her turn.
She's selling her ticket.
Don't believe her.
I got help but homie out real quick.
Wait, I gotta double check.
This?
What the fuck is this?
Okay, I'm like, he sent you a yeah he said he'll pay me back
in crypto guys all right let's see what the fuck is this
okay what is this
um i am confused
all right give me a sec guys i just gotta make this purchase
real quick what is it this what is that guys i think they
got into my guys i think it's a scam
minute I wrote are you the real blank and then and then he
was like yes motherfucker like I clicked the link though
are real.
Damien.
It sounds real to me.
And what?
I don't know!
Okay.
Guys, I think it's real.
Because he sent me an image that said certified
certified dumbass, but the dumbass was another word that is
similar, but I can't say it out loud.
I can't,
I think, I think it's real.
So I think, wait, wait.
This is not...
This sounds legit.
It looks legit.
Shader, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Thank you for the tier one sub.
Maybe scammers have evolved.
The sc- Yeah, they're getting a little cli-
Okay.
I- and then just to be safe, just to be safe I was like wait
wait text me just to be safe because I was like I because I
was like you have mine up texting me just to be safe and
then I just got the text and the text was you are fucking
slow all right we're in the clear we're in the clear the
two-step verification Guys, we got the two-step
verification.
I have to check!
That's...
False alarm.
We got the two-step verification cleared.
She got her phone hacked, guys.
The scam goes deeper than we thought it would.
Alright.
Which one was it?
Uh...
I can't believe you think I would fall for a discord scam I
Yeah, who knows if a donkey would I, you're right, I would
fall for a discord to fall for a discord scam That's true, I
would I was like, and then I text back, if you are real, um,
if you are real, message me on Steam.
I should have said that if you're who you are, message me on
Steam as well.
We'll do a three-step verification, you know, three steps to
see if everything, to see if everything was compromised.
all right what was it to have to buy again okay what is this
uh i need i'm on there's like several options this one is it
this is it this one also what is this what am i buying
Send the picture to the street and say Click anywhere if you
see a bus Yeah dude make the smoke signals I'll look up in
the sky Alright Alright I'm buying it And I'm shipping it
over To them
Oh What the fuck this guy This guy is stupid
all right
oh my god wait am i stupid or is he stupid
he's like no it's not like you can do this he's like no you
cannot oh wait do i not have double authentication on
guys guys for for security and privacy sake i definitely
have double authentication on on my on i i i definitely have
it on yes all right let me all right i need a change the
address here uh continue to check out and change it yeah
right add new address uh
then copy and paste
and then
Place order.
There we go.
Alright.
Alright, now we can watch the showcase.
Sorry, there's a long yapping stream on my Twitch.
On Twitch.
But now!
Now we can finally watch the showcase, guys.
Now Sound Guy can be here.
Alright.
Yay!
Summer Game Fest!
All right All right, okay, I'm watching now
Yeah, wait is that Kyle I'm
guys guys?
Yeah, I played guys Yeah, I played street fighter with that
guy
Yeah I played street I had he was on my team He's that guy,
you have voice you heard?
Yeah, I played Overwatch with him last night.
Yeah, that was me.
Oh, wow.
I'm so cool.
I play with a gal that announced Jeff.
I'm one degree away from Jeff now.
It's a good one, don't worry.
All right, hello, everybody, and welcome to Summer Game
Fest.
Gaming biggest global show.
case of what's next you know we started sbf back oh yeah
wait wait wait give me a sec sorry i gotta oh crank it up we
need to hear jeff's lovely voice okay let me crank it up
real quick see for this one i can um i can pause it you know
it might not be live but i'm able to pause stuff and then
turn it up instead of make missing things out also i need to
realize uh you know i need to do a ad real quick.
I don't know if they fixed it, but you guys didn't know for
the concert tickets in July.
Stream tickets are out, but apparently
it's like a little bugged right now to buy tickets because
they buy streaming tickets because you need a Japanese
address, and that should not be a thing.
that should not um that shouldn't have happened so um so you
guys they're trying to fix it right now to make it so that
his lap like uh it was got a little buggy so you need a
japanese address or something um but that shouldn't be a
thing guys it was just a little bug so i'm waiting till they
fix it before i announce it basically so we're just gonna
have to wait a little bit until then we want to go there in
person you can buy tickets!
Yay!
Did they delete that tweet too?
Oh, they deleted it.
Wait, they deleted the streaming tickets tweet.
That's funny.
I guess they'll make the tweet again after it gets fixed.
So I'll just advertise my concert tickets right now.
You can grab tickets right now.
right now um for my concert my 3d concert in la yippee
uh all right yes all right hashtag ag done all right let's
play the video because we didn't want to lose that magic
moment every june when gamers around the world I wasn't
there Jeff, why didn't you Do you think now that I know Kyle
He'll make sure that it won't Overlap with any of my
business trips when he does Announcements I'm like Kyle,
this is my schedule Please make sure that When you do these
announcements That I won't be traveling
No, I did crank him up There you go game developers yeah why
gaming's best days are right ahead of us what i love about
sgf is that we i turn it up over at it it doesn't matter um
here's my turner and make sure there's no clown flicks
please right now i did jeff is just so quiet behind me in
just the first five months of 2026 steam saw a record okay
but how many of them are just how many of them are just like
uh what are used to mine your to use but mine bitcoin all
right but what's the percentage i bet you like 60 percent of
those games are there to mine bitcoin uh yeah acid flips to
be fair it is more accessible but i'm pretty sure like at
least 60 percent of them are either ai slop there to farm
bitcoin or acid flips.
In the history of this great medium.
Now sure, a cynic might look at those numbers and think, how
can anyone possibly break through with their game?
But then you look closer.
So far this year, 14 new games are estimated to have sold
more than 1 million.
Wow!
Wait, I played most of these.
They come from independent publishers.
Isn't that great?
Wait, I played like, I think I played 50% of those games.
brand new ips like newgenics windrows or far wait heroes of
mind of magic that sold well the newest one is the newest
one good experiences you want originality forces yeah but
it's a new mind of magic good you guys show up for them
really great so congratulations to all those games now you
know some games they become global blockbuster i'm not
trying out communities that love them deeply and today are
you up and more does jeff need to be louder the truth is not
every game has to be for everyone that's what makes this
medium so exciting right now and makes sgf so rewarding
because this show helps drive all right up and more next
favorite game today so get ready to get wishlisting should
we get on with the show yeah yeah jeff it's gonna be So
let's get started with our preview of what's ahead with our
first announcement.
I swear to God, the game changer is like, like the sound
balancing between, between the Jeff and the game.
It's, I swear to God.
It's like, it's like, it's like, Tom's 10.
It's just, I know it's, I know for sure, if it was
Bloodport, my Twitter feed would never shut up about it.
Guys, no spoil, pretend this is live.
Guys, I wonder what can it be.
Just like the last time, we were like, oh my god, I wonder
if it's this game.
I was like, you guys know it's this game.
Don't pretend.
Yes.
So, you're the American who called earlier.
Hello, old drama.
The sister of the men on the third floor.
Welcome to Paris.
It's so nice to meet you.
Oh, it's freezing.
That's a true horror.
Come in.
We don't want you to catch a cold.
I hate to say it, but your brother is well.
It says Genshin.
In we go.
Oh my god, new HD updates.
HD graphic updates.
My worst nightmare of French grammar.
Oh.
Oh, lo, lo, lo.
Me kill Pagay.
He's made such a mess again.
Think, I just cleaned it up a week ago.
It's like a boulder roll through here.
Huh?
I'm grandma.
Oh, that's a delightful mystery.
Does she live alone?
That's so sad.
Where are your kids?
You never get married?
Wait, that...
Did you see that?
fucking dumbbell maintenance man from this there's no way
that grandma's lifting those weights who else lives here
granny go with the biscuit yeah i was gonna say who else
lives here
oh it's my brother why
am i feeling like like like it's like i've never been in my
own apartment like in my in this apartment before
If it's my brother.
Oh, because I haven't.
I thought I have.
It's like my brother.
Uh-oh.
Who's there?
I was like, this is Resident Evil.
I...
Resident Evil...
I've never played Veronica before.
I...
I don't know what Veronica is about...
I had a feeling this was Resident Evil because the granny is
very Resident Evil coded.
I was just like, that, she looks so much like, like, you
know, the old people in Resident Evil.
Yeah, you know, there's something about, you know, the style
like Resident Evil's style, like Resident Evil grannies, you
know?
I was like, that looks like another Resident Evil granny
right there.
Yeah.
Today's players, thank you to Takahuchi's son and Capcom for
that incredible news.
now she looks like an evil resident yeah top independent
game studios in the world that's a capcom granny oh i saw
yeah that's the cuphead game i saw this on twitter studio
mdhr headquarters and today we have a special announcement
for all of you we're happy to confirm that development has
begun on a brand new hand animated cuphead video game Our
talented team is hard at work on this ambitious project.
Which will take Cuphead and friends on a fresh, exciting
adventure.
It's a Tumblr head.
It's still in early stages, but we look forward to revealing
more when the time is right.
Well, from all of us here at Studio M-D-H-R, thank you
for...
Oh.
I didn't know this was plugged in.
Ring, ring, ring.
Hello.
Yes.
Oh, my insider told me, guys.
I know, yeah, this is all live.
My insider told me about the Cuphead game.
So I could place the bet on, uh, so I could place the bet
online.
One more surprise.
A small team within our studio has been working in secret on
something completely different.
This new project is a love letter to the era that brought us
into the world of video games.
Wait, oh, the previous numbers that they're working on new.
I thought the new game was the...
Oh, okay.
It's pretty radica.
I thought the new game was the game that they are saying
that they're hand animating.
I didn't realize that they're making Cuphead, too.
Now in development at Studio MTHR, it's Mighty Cuphead
Adventure.
A new fast action platform shooter with arcade quality
graphics and amazing sound.
It looks like a Game Boy game.
Like a Game Boy Advance game.
That's cute.
I never played NES games, so to me it just looks like Game
Boy Advance game.
I never, like I said, never had Nintendo console.
Growing up.
There you have it.
Two brand new games.
Until GameCube.
A true 8-bit action platformer coming to consoles and PC.
And then a brand new game.
new hand-animated Cuphead game has been confirmed too.
Great news.
Alright, well now please join me in welcoming my co-host and
partner in a new game discovery website called Looking for
Game.
It's Lucy James, everyone.
Lucy James?
Thanks, Jeff.
I am thrilled to be back here at Summer Game Fest and I'm
excited to share in so many incredible announcements.
Now this next one is very special for me.
It's a game we've all been waiting to see for a long time.
Bloodborne 2?
Pre-alpha footage.
Bloodborne 3?
They skipped 2?
It's like the new...
It's like 22...
24 Jump Street.
They skipped...
Did you guys see that?
Oh, Sega?
24 Jump Street has finally been announced...
writing it um and they they skipped 23 jump street because
it already took it took too long to make
there's something the company rarely forget what is this
damn these sonic graphics go hard guys it's sonic but it's
souls in your sock.
It's like that, I feel like nobody talked about that Pac-Man
game they did.
Is it even out?
Is it?
I didn't even know that the weird ass revamped Pac-Man game
where it turns into a Metrovania game.
Yeah, like it came out and nobody talked about it.
Oh, is it isolation?
Alien isolation.
The Japanese caught me off real good.
Hi, I'm Al Hope, creative director of Alien Isolation 2.
I was not ready for it to be an Alien Isolation game because
of the Japanese.
On behalf of the whole survival team at Creative Assembly,
we were very excited to share our return to the survival
horror genre.
It's been 12 years since we released the first Alien
Isolation, and we're continuing what we started.
creating an authentic new chapter which builds on that core
isolation experience of escaping the terrified, unkillable,
relentless alien.
And this time, we're unleashing the alien on an unsuspecting
colony world.
From the claustrophobic confines of the colony itself to the
exporters.
We're releasing the alien in Japan.
Satisfaction is a new hunting ground for the Ultimate Apex
Predator.
Players will face a desperate struggle to survive and
escape.
And we cannot wait to show you more in the future.
Thanks.
Godzilla.
We're sending Godzilla back to Japan.
The ploy of the alien.
Thanks so much, Anna and Al.
Today we are honored to have one of Gaming's true
visionaries here with us in the audience.
For more than two decades, his work has reminded us that
games can be emotional and deeply human.
From Eco to Shadow of the Colossus.
Sending Godzilla to his face.
He has left an unforgettable mark on this medium.
Please join me.
is not there the one thing I know for sure the one thing I
know for sure is that coach like Kojima broke up with him
and Jeff tried so hard to get his attention a few years ago
we gave you an early glimpse at a way to sun's next game
then known as project robot well now it's time to step
deeper into the mysterious unsettling and epic world that
marks okay I I did see the picture of them getting dinner
today, but you know that was just a pity dinner from Kojima.
It was a dinner where he's like, please stop texting me,
bro.
Like, please stop.
Like, it's over.
You didn't know it was a pity dinner.
Just be like, please stop.
Please stop making it.
Please stop making it such a big deal.
Let me believe mom and dad are still together.
It's like, he's just trying to set boundaries, you know?
He was trying to, you need to let me go.
Like, it's over.
Stop making this so weird.
You just stop telling everyone.
Nate, thank you for the, oh my God, Nate, thank you so much
for the 10,000 videos, Nate.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
first game in a decade let's sign these papers I need you to
sign this so we can finally move on like that and then and
then Jack posts the picture oh
what wait I this one I did not get spoiled for this one
Shadow Colossus this one from Desmond shall of Colossus I
did not like the Guardian game though I found I was not a
fan of the Guardian game.
I liked all the other ones.
Just, I don't know.
The Guardian game felt really slow for me.
I didn't like the gameplay.
A boy in his robot.
I like Child Colossus.
I see Eko.
I think that's how you pronounce Eko as good.
I think Child Colossus is like their most well-known game
out of the front, like, out of the, like, from the company.
Oh, it does look like Iron Giant, yeah.
Oh my god, big giant, giant robots fighting.
Oh my god, it's like those beat-em-ups, like the beat-up
robot where, like, two robots are, like, pow, pow, and then
you hit the head up.
It reminded me of that.
I like how Taito flashed for, like, one second.
I couldn't even...
I cannot wait for Gen Atmos like gen atlas okay it's just
travel to the east to china circa what is it called for the
title flash for one second and then it's like they ran out
of frames they ran out of money just to put the title in
they like we like they're like oh times up blood message is
a cinematic single player action adventure game from netty's
You are a messenger from the barter on a perilous eastward
odyssey with your son fighting against an eddies game Yeah,
and that is I
Swear that title was there for like three frames Like two
two frames or something and I'm in three.
It was a two frame flash.
I was like excuse me.
Oh
Oh stuff this is chinese uh chinese history
is this three kingdoms era what dynasty is this
oh shit
I like the graphics, but this is all pre-rendered, so like,
I, you know, I can't tell what is actually gonna look like.
Like,
I don't know if this is actual gameplay or if this is
pre-rendered.
Apparently a new single-player game from NetEase.
You know what I want to know?
I want to know when the Wukon, new Wukon DLC is going to
come out.
I'm still being sent Wukon packages, by the way.
I really appreciate them sending me Wukon PR packages.
they're really they're really nice yeah I they don't even
tell me like it just shows up yeah they just I would just
receive a box I was like what is this and then it's a Wukon
shit they don't I'm not even notified about it it just shows
up outside my door like yeah I was like yay free Wukon merch
yeah it's It's so cool of them.
It's like, yay, happy birthday!
I got blood message.
Now please welcome a game developer who is visiting the US
for the first time in two decades.
From RGG Studio, it's Masayoshi Yokoyama.
20 years.
Oh!
Oh, this is for Strangers in Heaven!
Oh, is it because of Snoop Dogg?
Yeah, you guys didn't know.
I got sponsored...
I got sponsored by Sega to do a reaction video of like their
trailer for it.
Hello everyone, this is Yokoyama.
So I do know about this game, yeah.
Today we have an exciting new update about Stranger Than
Heaven.
First, please take a look at this.
Yeah, it was a short video.
Yeah, I saw this trailer.
...
Guys,
damn, that shit must hurt, though, having your entire body
tattooed like that.
Oh,
it's from the same devs as Yakuza.
Apparently it's gonna be similar to Yakuza.
Snoop Dogg that's crazy like that's so much money I don't
know Snoop Dogg is not cheap I was like Tupac that I thought
I was fucking crazy like I can guess I knew he faced his
death he put like he he downloaded his consciousness into
it's like tron guys it's tron he downloaded his
consciousness into this into stranger than heaven like so
that's where he's been guys he got east of guide he got east
of guide into a video game he uploaded his consciousness
before dying we got a lot to talk about but first of all
we've
i knew it i knew he faced his death that was wild what's
next we're gonna get tupac android later they're gonna make
a tupac android to tell you more about that i'd like to
bring out a special guest Please welcome Snoop Dogg.
Snoop Dogg.
A grandpa now, when you think about it.
Snoops,
everyone's talking about this game.
Yeah, he's like in the 60s now.
You know his son?
His son is a Twitch streamer?
I mean, I'm a big fan of Sega.
I've been playing that game.
since it first came out and you know to be associated with
such a great game and such a great person like this and a
team that they put together it's an amazing you know feat
for me so I'm happy to be a part of it now we got to talk
about what just announced in this trailer how's Tupac being
a part of this you know we the Tupac estate and my son and
myself we work very closely together so it just made sense
to put him in in this game because his likeness and his
spirit still lives on and I just feel like it was so
connected to what we doing so what y'all think game looks
insane i'm sure you got more surprises in there too i know
the song sounds great um well we're looking forward to
hearing more on uh strangers in heaven i also want to ask
you though about something a couple years ago at tga you and
cordell talked about death row game do you think he
remembers i will say you know it's like do you remember time
when we talked about blah blah blah and i'm like do you
think he remembers i'm just because is he like high all the
time like like i i feel like like even for like anyone yeah
like for anyone um did he quit i'm just saying when did he
quit because like you know that affects the brain camp that
does that like the brain development for being high for so
long for so long for like for very frequently it's yeah yeah
you you i always wonder like How does that affect your like
brain chemistry and brain development?
So I'm like, do you think he remembers?
Like, I heard, I remember reading about this, but like, you
know how he pays people to roll up his, like, you know, roll
up his weed, obviously.
And I'm like thinking, like he pays a lot of money for
people to just roll, roll the he is to the game like yeah
like I don't remember what the pay I need to look that up
actually Snoop Dogg's guy yeah where do I sign up yeah so he
has a professional blunt roller um she works for Snoop Dogg
on a full-time basis rolling up to 150 joints a day to
accommodate date that 150 joints a day the salary was
initially listed as 40 000 to 50 000 a year but she has
confirmed there is a pay raise to combat inflation she also
receives free weed all travel expenses paid and
complimentary clothing that snoop is gifted she oh my i i
just a hundred and fifty a day
since I where do I that's why I'm like do you think he
remembers like when he's like remember the time I talked to
you about this last year a couple of years ago and I'm like
I don't think he remembers what happened last month I
I'm just wondering does he remember what happened last month
like yes sir death row games you know we're building a
hip-hop game he is reading a he's reading he's reading he's
what are they called he's reading a prompter he's that's not
that's not a natural response that's
that's toky's having it out for snooze I'm just saying
there's no way Jeff is looking at him and he's dead he's not
looking back at him if you know what I'm saying we just got
a lot of plans that we plan on actually bring it to life in
the next you know couple of months okay oh now he looks
hopefully hear more on that soon yes sir thank you very much
snooped on thank you just jealous he's living his life
More crazy stuff to come.
All right, next we're excited to announce the stunning debut
title from a new studio in Sweden.
Hex is an open-world action-adventure game from key creators
behind the division and little nightmares.
Not a hater.
I'm just asking questions.
Am I not allowed to ask questions?
This is a very cool game.
Take a look.
No, I'm just curious.
Gordon, thank you for the hundred pitties.
Thank you.
It doesn't come with dental.
Well, they made their own language and everything.
Is this an extraction shooter?
I don't know.
I'm a little worried.
It feels extraction coded.
Let's...
Oh shit, that's a giant nest.
Oh, it's the cube!
It feels very extraction shooter coded.
Not gonna lie.
Oh?
Welcome to the cube.
I love that movie, by the way.
The cube.
How do you even pronounce that?
I can't wait to see more from Hex.
Oh, Hex.
Okay.
We have much more SGF to come, but first on June 14th, Dead
by Daylight is celebrating its 10th anniversary.
Watch this closely because here's a little tease of what's
ahead.
Oh, was it?
It's coming.
That's the cap.
Everyone's like, was like, oh, who's going to be the new
character for Dead by Daylight?
trailer.
Everyone's freaking out, but it's literally just competitive
tag.
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Are you three?
Are you four?
Are you five?
Yeah.
Hey, six, seven does.
You're invited.
Yay.
How old are you now?
I would say for 10 year anniversary though um i could see
that some people can tend to feel that's underwhelming
because it is a 10 year anniversary so like you know it
could be anything for like the new killer release so i just
feel like i like it it seems to be like a character that you
can get of any other updates you know i think some people
were more hyped for we're hoping for slender man i saw
people were like, oh, what if it's Slender Men?
Blah, blah, blah.
Because it was, like, in the woods.
I don't even know what that other game was.
I just...
Oh!
It's, like, build your own.
Build your own traveling mecha.
Oh, it's Western-themed.
Oh, it's Brunseum!
What is it called?
It reminds me of that CSD's game, but what if you're in a
desert?
Right?
Yeah.
Or Icarus.
No, I feel like it's like Desert Sea, like Sea of Thieves.
Yeah.
Sand of Thieves.
Return to Sandland.
Sand Raiders.
This would be a fun multiplayer game.
Is it dangerous?
Yeah, it could be a fun member.
game too yeah edward privateering is it dangerous wouldn't
pay so nice if it weren't oh yeah is this assassin's creed i
never played um the pirate assassin's creed i don't know i
think like when you talk about assassin's creed everyone
will remember the original trilogy more um because it was
like It looked at Desmond's story, and they ended Desmond's
story in three.
So, like, I feel like...
Yeah, the SEO trilogy, yeah.
Can you feel it, Adé?
I never played Assassin's Creed IV.
We're moments away from the grandest prize of all.
I like the Desmond's story.
I thought it was very interesting.
So I was really sad that they ended it.
I'll save me a spot in hell, Shaka.
I ain't coming soon.
Yeah, so I was sad that they ended in the end.
Welcome back to SGF.
That was Assassin's Creed Black Flag Resynced, which is
arriving July 9th.
Now it's time for the announcement of a game that reunites
one of the best action game developers in the world with a
legendary franchise.
eyes yeah i would love to try a black flag i never played
that game before i think like i stopped giving a fuck after
desmond died i not died sorry not died after they ended
sorry not died but like after they ended his story
what's this
they are teenage mutant ninja The last Ronin teenage- I was
like, is this not THB the Ninja?
Like, am I not?
Oh, shit.
Wait, is he the last Ninja Turtle?
Wait, which one was Platinum Games developer?
You guys haven't been fun yet?
We are just getting started, believe it or not.
No, I don't.
That's another TMNT game from Platinum Games that I cannot
wait to learn more about Last Ronin.
Oh, Banetta!
Please welcome two-time TJ.
loser for Expedition 33 and Final Fantasy I don't know the
last Ronin story I didn't pay attention too much of the oh
Fortnite enough about Ninja Turtles it's Fortnite time hello
summer game fest for the past little while I have had the
incredible opportunity
And today, I finally get to share a glimpse of where that
journey is heading next.
We've been working on this for a long time.
A new season is about to begin, and everything is about to
change.
Let me show you what's coming in fortnight's next season
runners launching later tonight.
Okay, I'm going to pause this real quick.
Thanks, Jeff, for letting me pause the stream.
Let me pause the showcase.
like Doki needs to talk everybody stop everything um but for
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles I didn't read much of the
comics by the way for those who never read the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles comics it's really dark I know like all
the TV shows and like the cartoons the movies they all it's
all fun kid-friendly shit but but it's a great animation but
the comics itself it's so much darker like even the original
comics um even the original comics before they got their
first like i don't know i think the anime animated
adaptation you know all radical calabunga all that shit um
the original comics itself was like black and white and like
super like hardcore and like incredibly like dark compared
to like what it eventually became like you know it's all
about pizzas and then i remembered back when i was in my
transformer like like huge transformer era and i was reading
like the more than meets the eye the Starscream comics and
stuff.
I read a little bit, saw a little bit of the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles.
Yeah, by IDW.
Because, you know, I was looking into IDW comics and
everything.
And I just remembered, like, it was the arc that I read.
The arc that I read was the one where one of the turtles is
like a zombie.
how to phrase it it was it was so it was so fucked because
it was basically like she was like constructed from
different turtle parts and like she became this new it was a
new character and she was like reconstructed and everything
from different songs she was like a franken turtle like a
frankenstein turtle and it was like pretty dark yeah and it
was like and it was it was weird it was such a weird arc
yeah i'm talking yeah it was her was her name venus but let
me look it up I just I'm like vaguely remembering the comic
I read about it um
that was the last time I like that was the last and first
time because like the the fucking paddle for it was just I
was like whoa I was like oh my god I was like oh my god they
made a they made a franken turtle I
um and it was just it was such it was weird it was so weird
i was just like oh my god what the fuck is that like um wait
i'll grab the image it's like oh my god i did not want it to
be that big like this was the car like i saw this panel and
i read the arc for it i was like oh my god Like, that's so
weird.
Yeah, because I was like, this is Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles.
And, like, in, like, the virtual comics for it is super dark
and everything.
So that's, like, what I know about, like, the con...
I didn't hear about the last Ronin.
I just knew about...
I just knew about that.
Like, I just knew about that.
That's...
I know, it was weird.
It was such a weird...
I don't know.
It was...
All I can say is, like, it's fucking weird.
It...
Anyway, let's go back in.
Sorry, Jeff.
You can keep on going.
Let's see.
We're dead!
Oh, the Swaridane announced the little guys.
New season.
Bro, that shit gets serious.
People nearly sniped you for these little guys.
Like, snipe you from the battle bus.
I like how it's so hardcore, like so serious, the voice
acting.
And then these other guys are like, So what do you
mean by this stream was so broken, like when it was live?
I heard when it was live, like everyone's streams were
buffering and stuff.
yeah I heard about that oh my god John Wick he's back I need
to buy POM yeah is POM he's still in the store I oh yeah by
the way for those who don't play fortnight for those who
don't play fortnight um these little guys except for okay
it's really funny because it's it's pretty it's pretty funny
but uh these guys um people are so desperate for these guys
because there's rarity it's like gotcha it's basically like
they you know they took advantage of everybody's need for
gotcha gotcha everything so um um to get them they're like
rare they're like rarity rates for all of these guys and um
and you have to find them in the on the map and stuff and um
and you the only other way to get these little guys is by
killing a person that has these guys equipped already so
they it gives like buffs and buffs and stuff uh in fortnite
um so you have to equip them if you want like an advantage
in the game but if you have them equipped they can be stolen
um and you if you have them equipped you can also level them
up to make him stronger but if you get it then you have to
buy it back and and it resets your level to level one and so
what people do what the good players do instead of trying to
find these little guys whatever the fuck they're called um
they would stock every they would stock everyone in the
waiting room in the waiting screen and see whoever has a
rare like rare sprite equipped and then on the battle bus
they would wait for the guy to leave the battle bus and then
land on him to kill him so they can have the so they can
have their little so they can steal their little guy yeah I
saw videos of it it's so bad like it's so fucking bad like
they literally stalk you on on the fucking on like as you
get Ejected from the battle that but if you have a rare one
equipped.
Yeah, so it's basically an extraction shooter So you can
lose these you have to buy them back with your own money and
Like with your own like obviously not real money, but you're
like, you know, like XP money and but it resets the sprites
to level one if you lose it
Let me see if I can find a clip.
I'll send you guys a clip of it.
It's actually crazy like I
I saw I know like Nick posted a tweet about him like this is
how you can get and everyone like was like wow And then he
had a generational crash out about posting the video about
it's like it's like social media is a disease You can never
have it you can like everything you tweet out is just always
filled with negativity and it's a cesspool Like he had a
generational crash out Because everyone I was hating on him
for you We're posting the video.
They're just like, why?
They're like, bro, why are you bullying kids?
I'm so you can find it.
When was that announced?
Let's see.
I'm trying to see if I could find that exact.
I want to be deleted.
There's no way he deleted it.
of a crash out there's no way he crashed out that badly let
me see it where is it
all right no not this one oh there it is I found it it was
this video it's just
He's like, this is how you could do it.
And then you see him stalk.
I don't even know how you saw that.
These are like actual extreme gamer eyes.
I didn't even see it.
I don't know how you saw the guy fly out with that sprite.
That's crazy.
It's so tiny.
Those are actual like Fortnite eyes right there.
But yeah, that tweet sort of went semi-viral because
everyone was calling him out for it.
And he had a fucking generational crash out on Twitter about
the whole thing.
All right, back to the stream.
If you're wondering how we end up on this new island, you'll
have to jump into the shattered event happening live inside
Fortnite right after Summer Games Fest.
Oh, IDFK, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
This season we ask every player to choose a side.
And in the live event, that choice changes your experience.
It has all been building to this moment.
The party starts at 7 p.m.
Eastern Time, but the doors open early.
And trust me, you'll want to stay to the very end of the
event.
a little surprise waiting for you oh a little surprise the
stage is set oh it's more lore you chose your oh hey I chose
the rock he never loses it's in his contract this ends now
but he lost though guys he never loses It's in this cat
track.
Now it's time for a special announcement from Bandai Namco
about one of the most influential sci-fi franchises ever
created.
Oh?
What is it?
On Earth, mankind measured time by seasons, not sirens.
For a moment, it becomes void when you join Fortnite.
They're inside!
Out here, that promise is a lie.
What's this?
Whoa.
Are you okay, ma'am?
Oh, it's not a Mecha game.
Is this the era of Mecha?
We've had a lot of Mecha games recently.
Every breath taken is inside an armored shell.
Mechas are cool, Joe.
They are I did giant robots chicks dig giant robots You dig
giant robots we dig giant robots Where is Gundam?
Wait, she has the Gundam eyebrows It remembers one man
I did not expect oh now it's Now, you can tell what, guys,
you guys, you think this is the gameplay trap?
Okay, the jump between pre-rendering and gameplay always
gets me.
I...
Oh, it looks cool.
It's like, this looks like...
Oh, yeah, Gundam Monster Hunter, yeah.
I wonder if this is gameplay.
The trap...
Ah, it's a little...
It's a ball, yeah!
That's cute.
I love it.
this little guys thousands of games launch every year so
finding your next favorite can be tough that's why i'm
launching my new newsletter looking for game they're so cute
those little guys i'll be curating and selecting games that
deserve your attention every week and sending demos and
exclusive gun the monster hunter that's interesting head
over to looking for game to sign up guys they have to try
something guys they're gunned the hero shooter failed yeah
yeah they got they have to find their genre so they just
trying to find the genre guys look the hero shooter one
didn't work out to be i heard i heard that the hero shooter
one um it it's just because they were if they went to pay
the win i heard that's why it like i never got a chance to
play it i told you guys i really i've always i wanted to try
it but the perms for that was so that I was too scared to
stream it because like the rules for it was crazy like it
was like you it was like you can't do this you can't say
that you can't do this and I was so worried I was gonna mess
up that I didn't want to risk it and uh it was like it was
like so many rules to streaming that game and and I was just
I was scared because I was like I didn't want to fuck up and
like get in trouble so i never streamed the game and i never
played it and i wish i did because it looked really it
looked really fun and everyone's saying it was really really
fun but i heard that it was extremely paid a win and um it
was extremely paid a win and uh and like a lot of the cool
things were locked behind a paywall so that's why like uh
that's why i heard that's why i died Speaking of fun,
unexpected games, this next title comes from a solo
developer.
Thank you for the 300 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
It is a co-op physics game about...
Yeah, they basically shot themselves in the foot.
I saw that, yeah.
It's like made by one person, right?
Be careful, be careful with our little baby.
Don't drop it, don't drop it.
I'm gonna drop the baby.
Careful!
Oh my god.
Oh no!
Okay, new plan.
This is a good one.
Stop poop out another baby.
What is this?
It's way too hard.
Watch out with our baby.
Oh shit.
Just focus, please.
If we work together, I know we can do it.
How?
This is an extremely hard.
bait i don't think the egg is like fertilized maybe if we
look for some more people it would be easier oh wait what is
this like competitive like are they what is it co-op is an
extremely hard game oh that's clever i like that's a clever
name congrats hey dan what a fun it's like oh yeah it's like
the glass game what is it called it reminds me of the glass
game and infinity ward and another amazing studio i played
like i think i played like one hour of that game with my
friend and then i said i and then i refunded it i was like
carry the glass yeah and i played one hour of it and i was
like this and i was like no
Like, I ain't playing that game for free off stream.
I was like, you want me to suffer for free?
Not on stream?
Like, well, you mean a cat monetized my suffering?
See, that's why we're different.
I genuinely like most people.
Oh, then you're truly a sick fuck.
What is this?
TNM.
That's no moon.
What is it?
I mean, it has to be a planet.
Doesn't look like a moon.
I'll be coming for you.
Coming for us.
You're not one of them anymore.
Oh?
Oh, shit.
Don't worry, that man didn't have a family.
right just like you and me oh i'm shooter you guys don't
understand the real threat one person is selfing the other
is not that will not go so well imagine you get a stealth
teamer and uh in an action shooter in a co-op i'm just
containing the situation
why are they fighting fight those things together or die
alone what the fuck what is going on are they even human
guys i don't think they're on a moon guys oh you fight
together or die alone there's no way this is not multiplayer
like what the fuck there's two of them are you telling me
this is a single player game did they really fumbled it that
badly there's no okay crossfire okay there's no fucking way
they put two players two characters on the screen developed
character driven games with the goal of there's no way it's
not i'm not playing with an ai two opposing operators must
form a temporary alliance depending on one another is their
only chance i'm not depending on ai to support this
narrative we completely rethought how cover and traversal
work together and created a system that rewards tactical
thinking stealth and repositioning
Our player character, Layla, dynamically adjusts her stance
to react to the complex terrain and the enemy's line of
sight.
It fundamentally changes your relationship with the
environment and becomes an active skill to master.
Shout out to our amazing team at That Snow Moon who are
meticulously crafting Crossfire.
It's for all of you who, like us, love high agency single
player story driven games.
Player story driven.
I'm gonna get water, guys.
I'll be right back.
I gotta hydrate real quick.
And I'm back.
That's actually crazy.
They showed us two characters.
And they showed us two characters.
And they're like, single player game.
What?
I don't know.
That feels like such a fumble.
Like...
Well, the thing about Last of Us is that...
One was a child, you know?
So one was a child, and then you could literally tell her
to, like, stay there.
You know?
But, like, this was two adults have guns.
They both have guns.
Like, I hope they do add a co-op option.
It feels very co-op-y.
And I don't know.
It just feels...
it just it feels like it feels like it feels like a more
co-op-y game and usually i like usually in the last of us
you know it's joel was by himself a lot too so it wasn't
just like oh um he that the other character was always there
but in this one i just feel like that guy's like glue to me
so i do i hope it's a co-op game
and Taylor.
Now, last year at the Game Awards, we introduced the next
game from Remedy Entertainment.
You know what else you introduced, Jeff?
At the mind-bending world of a troll resonant.
Why don't you address that other game you announced?
It's been seven years.
The oldest house has fallen.
Everything we tried to contain is now loose in the streets
of Manhattan.
This was caused by a new type of hostile resonance.
is beyond anything that we can currently measure oh is this
control it's all quite terrifying it's like yeah oh it's
like the sequel to control yeah i remember we saw that
actually i remember i was like wait this i saw this i know
guys i we never finished control it was so much for you guys
it was i'm sorry it was a lot of reading
This is like a song.
Okay, out of the way too is just because I really didn't
want to start from the beginning.
I really, it was like freaky.
And I want to replay it all the way from the beginning.
And I thought it would be weird if we like start the game.
because you know the boss for the beginning of it is gone so
so it'd be weird if i'd start it from the middle right now
it's time for another summer game fest exclusive the
announcement of the next game in a storied franchise oh
exclusive what is this
Oh!
Anyway, it looks like...
Oh, what is it called?
You all have our own reasons for coming to this vast
frontier.
What did they bring us?
We who protect this land.
One of the most exhausting details were in MMOs in
existence?
You feel it too.
We see it in your eyes.
MMOs?
All you can think of is Final Fantasy.
That ships this land of awe.
At the great spirits to whom we are bound.
At the gods who hold dominion over all.
We cannot guarantee your comfort or even your safety.
But if you yearn for horizons unexplored, well, you can be a
bear!
For fellowship and purpose.
For a cause worth dying for.
To you, we can promise.
What is this?
Oh, Guild Wars.
Oh.
I never played.
I've heard of Guild Wars, but I never played it.
You know, good for MMOs for not dying out like RTS.
Good on MMOs.
I'm Colin Johansen, the studio head at ArenaNet, and I want
to thank you watching the exclusive first look at our
upcoming game the time is right for the next evolution of
the mmo rpg and that game is guild wars 3.
i think the mmo i played for was world of warcraft that's
just like not consensual world that is both beautiful and
fun to explore non-consensual world of warcraft and combat
while ushering an entirely new type does that mean my dad
forced me to play the game by launching on PC and
PlayStation 5 we're inviting the biggest audience yet to
experience the world of Guild Wars.
We're so excited to welcome all of you to join our story
before.
I told the story before, but for the newer dragons here, or
like the ones that missed out every time I told the story,
but basically my dad loved World of Warcraft, but he was
antisocial in the, well he wasn't like super antisocial in a
way where he doesn't, like, he usually, like, but he likes
to play MMOs solo like i know it's weird um but like in
world warcraft he needed a support he needed a healer
because he all he wanted to do was get to was level 80 uh he
need he wanted to get to level 80 and so he could have a
flying horse or a griffin or whatever i don't remember what
the mounts are but his entire goal was to get to level 80 so
he can finally have a mount that could fly uh yeah so um so
basically every time I came home he made me he made me
download World of Warcraft so he could put me on support and
basically uh be like his pocket support when he plays World
of Warcraft and so so I get home from school and then he
bought you know he gave me the all the You know he bought me
this you know like back in the day I don't know if you'd
still do that but like before like Goodbye online Like time
or whatever like online membership You have to get it via
the cards You have to buy it like go to the store and buy
the cards and stuff So he would give me the cards so I could
you know Fund my account and stuff You know scratch it and
then enter the code and everything And yeah the game time
cards And then I go home And then the thing is he played on
Not like he played on like uh uh he played like not i think
it was like hong kong servers he played on hong kong servers
but uh the thing is for those servers it's all in chinese so
i had to learn how to patch the game in the english i had to
figure out how because like when you boot it you have to
have like the So I had to go on forums and everything to
patch my name in the English.
So I knew how the fuck to play.
So because I was just like, I don't fucking know.
Like I can't read Chinese.
I didn't learn how to reach.
I can listen.
I can read like at a third grade level.
But I don't think I can read World of Warcraft Chinese
client.
So I had to patch it like to turn it into English.
research on that and to mod my game like I was like by the
way I was a kid so I had to learn how to mod shit as a child
like and so I had like hundreds of tabs like like not 100
obviously 100 but like 40 plus tabs trying to figure this
out as a kid how to mod my world or warcraft and so like I
said after school, I got on with my modded world of Warcraft
and and then played and then played with my dad as support
until he got to level 80 until he got to level 80 and then
he was done with me and
so that's why I just I never, I didn't like more than
Warcraft I didn't, I didn't And that was why I did not like
much of World of Warcraft.
Guild Wars community, go to guildwars3.com to sign up for
our newsletter right now.
Thank you.
Tossed aside like Woody.
More like freed from my shackles.
The moment he was done, I stopped playing World of Warcraft
and never went back in.
And now, and now it's time to head to a brand new planet,
Dervin Aikos.
Now this is pod racing.
Oh, it's a pod racer game.
Welcome to Dervin Aikos.
Where champions are born and losers annihilated.
It looks fun.
Oh shit, you die real life too?
My sources say you've been making friends amongst our It
sucks that the Star Wars franchise is dying though There's
all nostalgia bait now Is that John Cena?
Did they scan John Cena's face?
That's John Cena, right?
That's...
Yeah!
Stay out of my way Like, wait a minute, that is face?
Wait, I don't see anyone.
It's like the face is so similar.
It felt like they modeled that face after him.
Is it?
Okay, wait, I gotta rewatch that.
That looked like his face.
I think I can rewind.
Besides, boys, obviously.
Like, I don't know.
Like...
The champions are born and losers.
Oh my god, did you see that alien?
It's a fall.
It's basically fall guys.
We're the joy of the...
Very familiar faces.
Wait.
That was a fall guys alien.
Right there.
Look at him.
Look at the guy you made fun of in high school.
That's a kid you made fun of.
high school and losers what a glow up
where's his face my sources say you've been making friends
among where is he oh my god racers that's his face do you
see it i see it that's his he just has a Mustache.
It's similar.
That, it has, it's like the mustache John Cena.
Anyway, what was I seeing?
Yeah, the Star Wars franchise.
The Star Wars franchise is dead, sadly.
I don't know.
They made it so complicated.
I heard the Grogu.
They killed off the Madness.
Mandalorian storyline a lot.
Like, it's, like, really bad now.
The Mandalorian season one was amazing.
But then, like, apparently the movie was really bad.
So sad.
Whoa, this reminds me of...
What was it, that space game?
It reminds me of that space game.
I'm trying to remember.
Signalis?
Yeah.
That's what it reminds me of.
It's from the epic guys though.
The Witch Space game.
And it reminds me of Signalis.
Oh, Tiny Bill.
Oh, it's Raff.
Raff too?
Raff DLC?
Raff is fun.
I finished the whole game.
This looks like Raff.
Wait, Rath multiplayer?
Oh, I mean Rath was multiplayer, but I meant like, as in
like, like enemy Rath players.
Rath Russ?
Oh shit, wait, what?
Wait.
Oh shit.
Wait, it's like from, it reminds me of like Sons of Forest
with Rath.
Okay.
rough last harvest it looks like rash plus sons of forest
right because like the crafting stuff reminds me of it a few
years ago we announced sega's plans to bring back many of
its classic franchises including jet set radio and crazy
taxi what another one is the ai fighter today we've got your
first ever look at the surprising scale and scope of the
next installment this is Virtual Fighter Crossroads.
Oh, okay.
I thought they were talking about the AI-crazy taxi.
Because they were like, what is Trump?
Yeah, I thought they were talking about that.
Oh, it was the Xbox showcase?
Oh.
Guys, I missed it on all the showcases.
I don't know which one was which.
Guys.
We haven't even watched the Xbox showcase yet.
How did you know?
We haven't watched it yet.
Guys, spoilers.
Wait, we did.
Wait, I did.
Sorry, I did watch it.
That was last week.
I'm just like Snoop Dogg.
Do I even remember it?
I'm Snoop Dogg but without the weed.
I don't need, I don't need it to stop remembering.
I just forget about any enhancements.
I don't need substances to forget.
My brain naturally is.
The Chinese mafia!
My brain is already built like that.
right just take it easy it's a triad oh i know that move i
saw that move with chun lee oh my god is that chun lee
that's your i saw that exact move is street fighting yes you
play the part of a fight legally distinct chun lee you are
lacking in kung fu
Kung Fu.
That's Pai Chan.
Who's Pai Chan?
What?
Yeah, me too.
I'm her.
It's been 25.
five years since runescape was born and 20 years tomorrow
that durial 321 wreaked havoc in fallador oh i know durial
321 is coming to console with runescape dragon wilds
playable now on pc and early access here's a new look from
developers of runescape never played runescape before few
survive the land of dragons
seek more than survival they fight they adapt they build
they strive boldly into the unknown, claiming dominion and
forging their legend.
Sorry, sorry guys, I'm not.
I don't play RuneScape.
What's this?
Oh, switch two announcements.
And tell that they asked Nintendo to please send something.
And Nintendo's like, B-Squad.
In ebbing spring.
Yeah, Nintendo was like, why should I send you anything?
I got my own direct to do.
Our shedding seeds made piles of rot.
Odions cast with tempers rare.
Intainted Claire Three virtues, no Not all we cast as this
for us
Whoa Find the fuck the guy has a spider on his head Oh my
god, you can have a wolf mount soul frame What kind of game
is that?
What genre is that?
It's grounded?
Oh, it's so it's like Warframe.
Yeah, it's grounded.
You're looking at a living fossil.
I played grounded one.
Stop stream.
Please tell me that was your stomach.
I played it with a friend, but like I didn't play him as
much as my friend, so it was practically just single play I
would just pop up every like every like week or like week or
two I would pop up like once every week or two And then
every time I was like, whoa, look at all these cool things
that he built and
gives me a tour like uh it was just it gives me a tour and
gives me gear and i was like are you ready to progress the
story and i was like yeah i'm ready to progress the story so
like you would just be building everything and then like you
know and then i go show up and we progress the story and
then i log off and then he would play like every day or
every other day and then i'll show back up and he's like all
right let's progress the story and
Yeah, and then...
Yeah, I skipped all the granny parts that lead...
Anyway, I be grounded.
Anyway, guys, I so be grounded, though.
Sure, you did.
What the hell did we get ourselves into?
Yeah.
can't wait to be grounded too you must have missed so many
hours and grounded some guys leave it to luck oh it's mafia
or the godfather let it ride on a roll let it ride sorry not
me you can have all the luck in the world But what matters
is the choice you make when the cards are on the table.
You know, Mafia still, oh yeah, Mafia.
It still exists.
I mean, obviously, yeah.
But like, apparently they control a city in Italy.
Like, I don't remember what city, like a specific city in
Italy.
Yes, that was indeed a young.
I'm trying to remember which city it was.
Man of Honor expands Enzo's dream.
in Mafia, the old country, this August.
Okay, can you imagine working on something for 16 years of
your life?
Back in 2010, the creator of Assassin's Creed set out on a
journey to build his next time-bending epic.
Today, after many twists and turns, it is finally time for
Patrice Desalais to invite you in to his war.
Yet again.
There ain't even a creator of Assassin's Creed.
Might be interesting.
I am I do want more new blood though like the whole like oh
from the creator of this game from the creator of that game
but like it's like the movie franchise movie it's like the
movie scene right now Hollywood right now where the new
people the new developers the new up-and-comers are creating
like um are creating like you know better movies and more
interesting movies for the new generation I have devoted my
life to facing them.
Those granted the power to raise souls.
Apparently this game is assed by their gifts.
Tilting the ancient balance toward cataclysm.
But at last, their debt is due.
Oh, I saw the, yeah, wait, I saw Twitter drama about this.
I remember People were not happy about this game for some
reason.
Every breath has led me to this moment.
As the moon bears witness, I take the first step.
My time has come.
I am ready.
I mean, the trailer looks good.
It sucks at the demo.
You would think when you release the demo, like, you know.
Oh, it's in Amsterdam.
released a demo you would try to have the best parts of the
game not like something you know oh and an AI boxer thank
you everyone 1666 has been a monumental and emotional
journey David Lynch once said like the development of a game
just to AI the box that's all I feel today about the game
instead of explaining features I'll simply say this as of
right now the prologue is free to Steam and Epic Game Store.
Yay!
Oh, it's Pro Live.
It's a 30-minute story experience and a muse bush, if you
will.
I'll leave you with a glimpse of what's to come when the
game launches on early access later this year.
Join us for the journey.
Merci and Panache Coalition.
It's too bad because it looks...
I like the...
Uh...
What's it called?
I guess like the feel of it.
Feel of it looks cool.
It gets me a witch.
The vibes.
The aesthetic.
Yeah, the aesthetic looks really cool.
The thing is, what's crazy is that AI usage is so popular in
Asia.
It like, um, and like I told, I said this before, but if
you're in Asia, Asia right now you'll see AI everywhere and
no one cares about no there's no like discourse about it but
like in obviously it's like it's such a conflict between
Asia and Asia developers and Western developers because like
in Asia people like don't see anything no problem with it
like I remember I was like I would just I was in the mall in
Asia and then it's just AI everywhere but it's just it's
such a common thing there now um um so it's like a conflict
between, like, the culture shock between Asia and the West,
between, like, what they see of AI.
Thank you, Patrice.
Still to come.
We've got a lot of great announcements for you, including a
special surprise.
Oh, I saw that.
They were like, Jeff.
Who's that?
Like, Jigsaw, get away from him.
Get away from Jeff, Jigsaw.
Billy from Saw.
Don't let, don't get Miss Piggy.
Hey, Bill.
Okay.
Hello.
I want to play a game.
Chicksaw, run!
Oh, we're not playing it.
Well, that's great.
We're here at Summer Game Fest.
This is all about playing games.
It's perfect.
Roll the tape.
You heard the puppet.
Run, Chicksaw.
He's into dolls.
He fucked puppets before.
I'm asking you.
Since the genesis of your legacy.
Oh, shit.
I really saw something.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Oh, my God.
But I call you a prophet.
A pain is our only true path to redemption.
It strips away the lies that people tell themselves.
Only then do they get to see.
Oh, what the fuck?
Makes them tick
A sacrifice must always People even play that saw
multiplayer game Remember that one Live or die the dead by
day not dead by day.
They saw a multiplayer.
It was like It's just like Outlast trials.
Oh, yeah, sorry.
I outlast trials just felt so cute Jigsaw life.
Your book bound in blood
inspires those who are worthy.
Damn.
The spiral bleeds.
Multi 3v.
Oh, it is Dead by Daylight-esque.
Three versus one.
Oh, it's like Outlast Trials.
Yeah.
It's like Outlast Trials slash Dead by Daylight.
like it's death run oh it's just death run
no sacrifice we are ready to bleed
the veil between realms is unraveling what is this life or
death holy this is a two hour this is a three hour showcase
I forgot how many games came out.
I...
Guys, I yapped...
Oh my god.
Maybe I yapped too loud in the beginning.
That's right, Lords of the Fallen 2 is also coming to Steam
this fall.
You said all of them.
Next up is a brand new game from Bitreactor.
A studio formed by some of the most experienced developers
in the tactic genre.
This is Star Wars Zero Company.
Star Wars Zero.
separatist fleet massing in the Ceralona system.
Then we need to make our move.
You got someone.
Zero company.
What do you got for me, Penic?
We're Zilius.
Coil's been spotted meeting with local gangsters.
Find out what they're up to.
I've been tracking Fathom for months.
She's at the center of it all.
All right, let's get a team together.
I didn't even try and prove it.
I guess the, what is it called?
The Star Wars Fallen Jedi was good.
So they're just trying to cap, like, recapitalize on that.
Oh, the Star Wars X-Cob?
X-Nobles, X-Cons.
And we're better for him.
We're almost there.
We just gotta finish this job.
up general skywalker
star wars zero company a little surprise at the end there
i've heard of scom i don't actually know much about it thing
the monster within and today one of europe's most ambitious
studios is ready to take you into a brutal new world where
vampires have emerged hiding oh come in vampire masquerade
who is called
oh shit the books please oh the amazon the vampires got an
amazon order oh yeah you can amazon order blood now
uber eats yes he over eats some blood
How convenient.
What the fuck is going on?
He's like, give me a sec.
Let me eat some blood real quick before we continue.
Time out.
I got a red guy refuel.
Am I evil?
They adore me.
You're a pawn in Princess's hands, nothing more.
This won't end well for you.
I've done the unthinkable for my own family.
My time and my blood delivery isn't here yet.
What the fuck?
How do we go from modern?
I thought that was more interesting than...
Wait, it's daytime!
How is he out in the open?
How many innocent Yeah, door dashing blood to Medieval.
Maybe we are so different after all.
I don't know.
I thought it would have been cool that it was during the
door dash part.
Oh, is it Vampire Witcher?
Hello, everyone.
My name is Konrad Tomoschkevich, and I'm the game director
of the Black.
It does look like Vampire Witcher.
What you just saw was an invitation to join us.
us on an adventure adventure through era eras and cultures
oh by the witcher devs yeah i thought it felt very witcher
like there i mean to be fair the the box art there the
pictures illustration is literally witcher core and it's an
origin story of coin i hope you will have as much fun
playing our game as we had making it thank you and have
great rest of the show
Next, the creators of Among Us have been hard at work Oh,
this is where they fucking silent drop And today we're
revealing it for the first time It wasn't really a first
time revealed Because they, for those who didn't know, they
like What's it called?
They shadowed dropped it on streaming services Before they
could...
Oh, wait, the game?
A standalone game?
Oh, I thought they were talking about the show.
Okay, I didn't know about this.
Oh, what?
You're doing a story?
Oh, it's a murder mystery.
It's a visual novel.
Oh, my God.
It's dead.
It's Eddie's Dengon Rampa.
Wait, this is Dengon Rampa.
We finally got our own Dengon Rampa.
from the Among Us TV series, please welcome Yvette Nicole
Brown and Liv Husein.
She's out of life, but she's right.
Hey!
This looks a little cringe.
We are so excited about the future of Among Us as crew
members are Oh, now this is what I saw.
News about the animated series.
This is what I saw.
Yvette.
Uh-huh.
Look, I know fans have been dying for updates, but there's a
dead body right there.
And the imposter could be any one of us.
Hmm.
Yeah, she's one of the voice actors.
I think this calls for an emergency meeting.
So you'd rather call a meeting than complete our task?
That's suspicious.
Yeah, that's pretty sus, girl.
I'll have to report this to Mira HQ.
Why can't I see the guy?
He's not even wearing...
I don't think there's any...
Wait, is he in a tank top?
And now, the moment you've all been waiting for, get hyped
for chaos, betrayal, and more in the Among Us series.
Enjoy.
I heard the show was really good.
Our fellow mates of crew have perished.
They would have prepped.
How are you talking so weird?
People were like, sad that the shadow dropped it.
The official cause of death.
Because apparently the show is really, really well written.
For those who didn't know.
It's written by the people who wrote Infinity Train.
So if you, I personally really loved Infinity Train.
So, and I heard a lot of really good things about this,
yeah, about this show.
So when it, yeah, so people, like the jokes are really
well-written.
Apparently the show is like really, really well-written and
everything.
So people were sad that...
They got fucked over, basically, by Paramount, because they
got shadow dropped.
Like, they basically did not do a lot of PR for it.
A lot of advertising.
Like, they got a lot of good voice actors and actresses,
too.
And then the advertising for it and the PR for it was so
bad.
I'm so happy to have you among us.
I saw some clips of it and it was really good.
Surprises at SGFR still to come.
Stay tuned.
And it turns out there's more coming.
Kind of drop.
One of this year's best reviewed games, 007 First Light.
Ooh!
I played that team.
A new story mission coming later this year.
We've received an urgent call from Aleph, James.
Guys!
We played that!
asked for you personally our alliance with bavma is fragile
at best but if he has what he claims to yeah i'm surprised
they didn't even put it in the act that was written it was
written by the same people who did infinity train go back to
lf and find out what this is all about because a lot of
people didn't notice that best of luck i only found out
because people were like sad about how how the guy got over
multiple times like you know they canceled infinity train
even though infinity train is so good i really enjoyed
infinity train yeah but they cancelled it they technically
fucked over the people who made infinity train
the time is finally here i know it's been difficult all
these years the unbelievers mocked you For your faith
tonight.
We shall show everyone how wrong they were
Okay Okay I
have no idea what's going on What what is this I
I'm looking to find the source of the disturbance.
Oh, it's an MMO.
Okay, do that.
I need a complete picture I'm sorry.
I always like just associate when I see MMOs.
I'm sorry guys Maybe the two of you really are from another
universe
Oh, I heard about this.
It's like the cyberpunk uh with littering waves.
Is that the one?
It's a gotcha game, right?
We're in ways with Cyberpunk.
I'll erase you at the finish line.
I heard about this collab because there was a gotcha player
that was crying about it because they actually converted
their currency to the wrong currency.
That's the only reason why I know about it.
Discord is looking for us.
Yeah, they like saved up for this collab for like months.
They saved up for this collab for months and then they
converted it to the wrong currency.
That was a look at what's ahead for Wurthering Waves and its
collab with Cyberpunk Edge Runners on June 8th.
Now, if you want to track all the games shown today, head to
player.gg slash SGF to see the full lineup and wish just
your favorites across all platforms.
Right now, it's time for news on a massive expansion coming
to a franchise that has been on this stage before.
Ooh.
Also, apparently They started giving you can do Oh monster
hunter But you can Do like Higher bit like not it was a
higher bit Right you can make it more HD now For twitch
streaming But I haven't done it yet I didn't want to I was
I'm too lazy to Fuck around and find out Yeah you do 1440p
now I mean we're watching We're doing a watch a lot do we
really 1440p for a watch a lot like do we really need that
we're literally we're just watching stuff but yes don't you
where is my 1440p watch a lot where Wow Joki you don't care
about us you don't care about the viewers my pixels only the
best visuals for reaction streams with just their presence a
moving natural disaster where's my boy do you watch a lot
toky i thought we were special sounds like an elder dragon i
have a 4k mod and you look bad toky watching in 4k but we
get 1080.
she doesn't care about us she hates us
2027 you
know it's all for nothing still you press on oh what's this
oh Oh,
is this Souls?
Is it Souls-like?
Well, obviously not Souls-like, but is this a Souls-like
game?
It feels like it.
I mean, the left side, guys.
Like, you know, the left side is very Souls-like.
Yeah, they have the heal pot.
They have...
Oh, no, the soundbar is...
the top left left
which way is left i can't tell it's not 1440 feet wait yeah
they even have the wukon stuff too with the little minions
oh is that a magic bar oh yeah it is oh it is a magic bar
it's not stamina oh wait that's cool they didn't summon
minions to body block wait I like that.
Oh my god, teamwork, guys.
Oh, it's like the face swap mask.
Which one's the real one?
Wait, which one is the real one?
Oh, there he is.
It's not.
How do you know?
How do you know, huh?
Swords?
Oh, new IP.
I feel like with the success of Ukan, Take your time.
There's been a lot of similar type games like this.
How do you know, huh?
This is live.
There was a new look at gameplay from Swords of Legend, a
fantasy action RPG.
There you saw a boss fight against Kong Kong Zi, with each
move pulled from real centuries old.
Thank you for the raid, Keeley.
Oh, we had a good stream.
We are doing a catch-up watch-along of all the game
showcases.
I know these were like two weeks ago.
yet but i missed out on it so i'm i'm getting uh i'm
catching up right now but thank you for the raid yes i know
this is live jeff decided to redo the entire summer game
fest just for me they're doing a take two oh hot wheels
wheels wheels would
wouldn't hot would be better than wheels would because at
least it starts with a H.
Hotwood.
Ha.
God, this is my fours of six.
But I don't play fours of six.
I play hot wheels.
Finally, a real game for real gamers.
Hot Wheels Infinite Rush.
Oh yeah, so I'm talking about Pac- I was going to say, like
the Pac-Man reimagined shit.
Nobody cared about that game when it came out.
Which was crazy.
They were put like so much into the reimagining of Pac-Man.
Oh, it's Sonic Crossroads.
Oh, wait.
Oh, that's cool.
Wait.
Avatar?
Oh my god, they have all the crazy collabs.
This is my cinematic universe.
I think I forgot about it.
Godzilla?
He's back?
What's this?
Oh my god.
What?
What are all the greatest crossover of all time?
A new indie game.
Oh, I saw this.
I want to play that.
That's Sonic Kiko part, gotta go fast.
That's crazy.
The fucking...
They're all there.
They got everyone.
Bring back the...
What was it called?
The PlayStation Smash?
You guys remember the PlayStation Smash Bros.
PlayStation All-Stars?
Bring it back!
Bring back all-stars.
Oh, I saw that.
Did you know they announced her making a sequel anime for
it?
I saw this.
That one was spoiled for me.
Dynasty War... It's Attack on Titan Warriors.
Yeah.
There's going to be an announcement on the sequel to Attack
on Titan.
Like an anime sequel.
Yeah, I know the manga ended.
Yeah, I was like, how are they making a sequel?
Like, what the fuck?
Like...
Yeah, what's gonna happen?
snapped it.
And attack on Titan three.
See even they have a sequel.
From many of the creative leaders behind Forza Horizon comes
a new cinematic open world driving experience set in Monaco
and the French Riviera where the worlds of pro and
underground for those who are like, what the fuck?
Studio Mappa.
confirms its return to attack on titan earlier map has
confirmed that's creating new animated segment for the
digital entry while fans will have to wait until 2007 oh
wait that's the um oh wait never mind that is where but yeah
they also have uh but they're planning on creating a new
anime in a surprise uh the uh the series hinted at new
original anime projects to come in a surprise It's creating.
Yeah, so there is planning to make a splash and Aaron
Yeager's world Oh, yeah, so yeah, you guys gotta wait
2000 sorry 2027 sorry can't read 2027 yeah, you got time
travel Sorry can't read
We have two drivers dead cars imagine imagine they reboot
cars reimagine cars i'm done my friend said you can help me
some people are meant to be outlaws theo think about it
what if cars had drivers
no way blasters me You mean the cars don't drive themselves?
I've tried to help you.
I'm not coming to jail for you.
What is this newfangled technology?
Clutch?
I don't even know what that game was.
Is it car action?
Cars, but with action?
but their sons will plant fear or respect
what is this
every battle yours oh you customize your little horsey oh my
god that pressure pressure but that's a pressure flag right
chronicles medieval in medieval time?
We're gonna get a lot of medieval games lately.
Is that the new zombie genre?
We're now back to medieval?
We're back to medieval area.
Oh, is that the Holy Roman Empire?
We have lots more summer game fest ahead and trust me, trust
me, you definitely will want to stick around.
This year, 2026, is medieval in Mecca.
Oh, another NetEase game.
What's this?
Our style is interesting.
Make it loud.
Every face feels out of line.
That's how I know they're all mine.
We don't fit and we don't care.
Broken chunks in broken air.
They said grow up at your age.
We just slide another flame.
Make it out, make it out.
The art style solely has like some rival, like Marvel Rivals
influence in it.
Like the colors, the textures, the textures are very Marvel
Rivals coded.
I don't know what this game is.
I can't tell.
I
mean, the trailer is cool, but what kind of game is it?
I mean, I love the art style.
Oh, there!
You see it?
One sec!
Oh, did you guys, did you see it?
Oh, it's a tactical RPG.
It's tactics.
In a world.
I think it was like 10 seconds.
Yeah, turn-based.
It's a turn-based tactical RPG.
Is it me, or is there something off with this one?
Yeah, he seems different.
Has he always had that mustache?
He doesn't have a mustache.
Oh, yeah.
Hey, buddy, what's your deal?
Howdy.
His that?
Name's Ryu.
What's all this mess about me being different?
Well, look at that.
He sounds different, too.
What in the Sam Hill?
Everyone in Tokyo talks like this.
I know what this is.
It's called a knuckle.
Yeah, I need to.
Our nation could have not done this.
Not a bootleg.
Yikes.
The Capcom Summer Game Sale is here.
Take home genuine, bona fide, 100% authentic, real deals on
select titles.
Nice.
I can't do it if you're watching.
Oh, that's awkward.
Ladies and gentlemen, representing the elite ranks the Ark
Society, Mr. Graves!
Let's see.
Oh, black and yellow, black and yellow.
Uh-huh, uh-huh.
Uh-huh.
Black and yellow.
Yeah, uh-huh, uh-huh.
Where's Khalifa?
I actually legitimately did not know who sang that song.
I just know that it was it's It's like slaps.
Oh, it's powworld Powworld's finally coming out, right?
I didn't even realize powworld was in beta this entire time.
I thought the game was fully fully out I did not realize
it's just been in beta
Yeah, it's finally in 1.0
Oh, yeah, and they won the lawsuit
Yeah, they can use balls again.
July 10th.
Yeah, where's the guns?
Why didn't you just shoot the dragon?
Powerworld 1.0 is coming out on July 10th.
Now, at the start of the show, I mentioned we'll have lots
of new worlds to explore today.
And the return of some long-awaited ones as well.
This next game falls into that last category.
it's been a long long long eight years long eight years oh i
saw that wolf among us each case husband and wife found it's
finally the sequel i never played wolf among us for a tell
tell game people are dying or like watched it i think at
that time i was just watching people play telltale games
because i wasn't you know i wasn't a streamer it's like why
play when i watch you know back in the day i was just like i
was watch big be sure if i never job within the week are you
living under i never played or watched wolf among us before
the reason i'm here i've only watched uh i've only watched
the walking dead one because you know everybody watched them
like that that was like the streamer game back then i knew
this game was really really popular especially on tumblr
there was so many girls who love this game the sexy tumbler
man yeah i just knew he was very he was one of the sexy
tumbler men
oh no i don't look human his lips are sealed but i'm not
helpless see around i was wondering when you turn up
looking for me wow
also did you guys see um what's that what's that anime
called that's right big B is finally back did you guys hear
they finally animated that scene and then Mac Mershure
voiced the president this holiday now this next game comes
from an acclaimed studio that is deep into development
surprised that they animated that scene of course they
didn't add they of course they did change some things and
they did change some stuff in that scene and Matt Mercer
voiced the president oh
I heard this is a stellar blade too right and I played the
first stellar blade game I'm
listening Scarlet Sin, that's the beginning and end of it
all.
How about you try taking a hit?
Wasn't there some AI shit?
It was the, it's because it's the director.
It's our first mission in a while.
The game director or the company?
Was it the company, right?
The CEO of the company is like very, very pro AI.
Quiet.
They're moving.
I just remembered it because, uh...
Because, uh...
People were really sad because the director is a very, very
talented artist.
Like, um, he's been known, he's like, his style is like very
unique in everything.
In the movies, this is always where things go wrong.
Hey.
Well, I'm just saying, it's a cliche.
Wait, the target stopped.
oh shit guys i think he has a tumor oh shit what the fuck
guys i think he needs some ibuprofen
damn i'm looking right now at the amazing action scenes and
blood and prompts and quick time events.
My eyes are up there.
Whoa!
Those are some good graphics.
You guys see the pixels?
Oh, you can because you don't have 1440p.
Stellar Blade Blood Rain.
That was a good one.
Shift up is returning to the world of Stellar Blade.
I wish you guys could see it too.
By the original team that's here today.
And they're playing the original.
The same universe as Stellar Blade this next chapter
continues the story beyond the events of the first game.
I think when Stellar Blade came out, a hundred million other
games also came out, so I never had a chance to try it.
We have more to share in the future.
All right, we're almost done, but not quite.
It's been almost exactly three years since Street Fighter 6
was released in June 2023.
Oh, was this the character release?
This is Street Fighter 6 Year 4.
This was the...
I saw this.
Guys, guess who's getting a free Street Fighter?
Street Fighter 6.
Guess who's getting a free battle pass?
Let's go!
No way!
No, you don't.
No, you don't even play this game.
That's right.
But I got a free battle pass
Free DLC
Shout out the Capcom Also got the ogle.
That's why I I asked for the Viper and Alex DLC because I
couldn't fucking like I couldn't fucking practice Axis
against Alex and Viper.
Oh, there's Difa.
Remember, this one everybody freaked out.
And then I was just like, can I get a free DLC so I can lab
against Viper and Alex?
Like, I was just like, I don't have access to it.
Nakayama-san, director of Street Fighter 6.
So they sent me a code for it.
Of Square Enix.
He drew me!
I met this guy!
I met him!
Thanks to all of you, Street Fighter VI has reached its
third anniversary.
Guys, I'm zero degrees from him!
I'm one degree from Jeff and zero degrees to that guy.
I have a original art drawn from him.
he literally drew me honda and addressed it to joki bird all
around the world that's exactly why our goal was this to
bring to life a tifa that's great don't don't make me don't
know i'm pausing this i'm pausing this i'm bringing the
receipts for those who don't have twitter i will make you
look at twitter i
Look at that.
That's right.
I'm gonna flex.
Look at that.
That's right.
You see that guy?
See him?
That's right.
Fake an AI.
Got a virtual art.
Didn't even...
I just asked for his autograph.
Look what I got.
It's so fake, it says Doki Brid.
Yeah, we get it, Doki.
Your bed is warm.
And your food is always, and you always get hot sizzling
steak.
As Tifa, the street fighter, Materia has also been
reimagined as a new gameplay system.
We cannot show it today, but we adapted an iconic Final
Fantasy element to the battle experience.
Maybe that's why...
Tifa's fight is far from over.
We hope you all look forward to what's coming next.
Maybe that's why he left.
Tifa went to Street Fighter.
And he was like, that's it.
Nakayama son for coming all the way from Japan to join us
for that special moment on stage yeah I found out Tifa went
to street fighter and he's like I'm done I know a one final
announcement guys any guesses now frankly I don't know what
I could say to set this moment up so he's just like I'm not
gonna say anything for the final battle He doesn't even hype
it.
He doesn't He doesn't want to do it again
That's a good sport about it One man sought dominion
Actually don't remember what the following I don't think I
got spoiled for this Oh that's why I didn't get spoiled with
this I did not I'm sorry I did not care as much
It was not in my mighty weapons not in my algorithm against
the celestial threat now hope endures in those who fight
long story short world's in trouble has been for a while so
what are we waiting for i mean i knew all the characters
i've seen these characters designs i it was i like oh my god
fortnite sorry um I didn't realize that tiger could talk
until like a couple of years ago.
I thought it was just like a pet.
And I was like, he can talk?
I was just like, what?
I'll make you proud.
Sorry, the cat.
I don't fucking know.
It's an animal next to him.
Like, I just thought it was like a giant animal.
There's a cat.
I don't know.
There's a dog.
Which was the dog?
I just see one thing.
Let us put your faith to the test.
That guy.
That one.
The Mohawk cat.
That's a dog.
Where's the cat?
I can't believe you.
This is clearly not a game.
made for me.
This was, I won't let you down.
It wasn't.
There's only, where's the dog?
Where's the cat?
Wait, where's the cat?
It was just that's the dog.
Okay.
There you have it.
And no, he's not done yet.
Please join me in welcoming back to Summer Game Fest, the
director of Final Fantasy VII, Revelation, Naoki
Hamaguchi-san.
But yeah, like I said, I didn't realize he could talk.
I I felt like he was just a giant pet.
Like, it was like...
I don't know, I didn't...
The gym thought it was just a giant...
Companion.
I didn't realize he was sentient.
I'm truly delighted to unveil Final Fantasy 7 Revelation,
which is launching simultaneously on all platforms.
You're skipping, you don't get, no, we won't skip, but maybe
I'll use the bathroom.
And we've only been able to come this far thanks to every
single one of you who continued to believe in this story and
waited for this moment with us.
The central theme of this title is Resolve.
Cloud and his companions each confront their own destinies
and find the resolve to marginally towards the final battle.
I too have carried a promise in my heart throughout this
journey, the resolve to see the series through to its very
end.
We're committed to delivering this experience in its
ultimate form.
Please stay with us and witness what lies beyond that
resolve.
Today, to help guide us on our path, please show me and
welcome to the stage the voice of Vincent Valentine, Matt
Marceler.
Thank you very much, Hamaguchi-san.
It's truly a privilege to be here with you today, if you
know me.
so much to see in Revelation, I think we just kind of need
to dive right in.
What do you say?
Let's do it.
Take it away, Matt.
I don't mind if I do.
As we reunite with our heroes, the meteor looms in the skies
above.
A constant reminder of your mission.
And the grave threats you'll confront as you embark upon
your journey and face the epic conclusion of the remake
series.
Aboard the highwind, your very own airship, and the pride of
the Shinra fleet.
You'll take to the skies and witness our most expansive open
world yet.
From the outskirts of Midgar, to the sun-drenched Medill
Archipelago, to the warrior nation of Wutai.
Simply pick a direction and set sail.
But how can you be expected to protect the whole world at
once?
You'll need to cover ground fast.
I am not jumping!
No way, no how.
Don't worry.
These parachutes are top of the line.
Roll a cord and pop.
You'll be floating through the air.
There's a cat!
I'm back.
Just a time to see the talking cat.
At any moment in the open world, simply pilot the high wind
to your destination and take a leap of faith.
Oh, that missed Mac Mercer.
With the wind rushing past, you'll descend seamlessly from
the sky above to the ground below.
Dokey and you have to play all of them?
Guys.
That freedom is in your hands.
But no matter your destination, to defeat your enemy, you'll
need a fighting chance.
Guys, I don't think we're good enough.
think that's ever happening with the world teetering on a
blade's as long as life streaming career is still alive
somehow each with their own story that brings you closer
together than ever but a good unit needs more than
friendship to save the day it needs a disciplined combat
regimen i don't really think you guys can cope about this
established and remake and refined and rebirth is perfected
in revelation putting even more power in your hands i'm a
chibi chocobo action seamlessly switch between not a regular
chocobo then when the fight calls for strategy i give out
the chibi chocobo vibes from the manga that chocobo
activates devastating synergies with your companions and of
course we call on mighty summoned entities that can turn the
tide that's right i'm not like other chocobos guys i'm the
stupid one in the manga
Summoning Efrid never gets old.
Oh, there he is!
There are truly some chill-inducing fights ahead in
Revelation.
I'm so excited to see all of your reactions.
It's going to be amazing.
I'm guessing you have a favorite character to frame,
Battooth.
I might be a little biased, but since you brought it up...
But how old is Max Mercer now?
He's pretty old now, right?
Vincent Valentine.
around for a while early 40s oh my god wait this okay guys i
late 30 i'm looking it up nobody knows anymore capable of
delivering precise high-end shots he's 43 oh he must have
started up he must have started when he was like
experimentation at the hands of voice acting like young
young transform into the galleon beast at the press of a
button gaining tremendous power he has been around for a
while hey pizza skills of a certain ace pilot yeah he has
been around in the scene for a really long time like at one
point it was just every main character was just voiced by
Matt Mercer or the other guy who's the other guy and their
what was his name again the other guy Troy Baker yeah at one
point it wasn't Troy Baker it with Matt Mercer for like the
main character.
The main character, guys.
To further augment your combat capabilities, try this on for
size.
Oh yeah, Nolan North too.
Tactical suit wear or the FITS system for short, allows you
to further customize your play style with new uniforms and
do with new uses.
Or Nolan North.
Alongside your equipment and materia, FITS gives you an
extra edge in battle.
And to face what's coming, you'll need all the strength you
can muster.
sensing its fate hanging in the balance.
The planet itself has unleashed its last line of defense.
The weapons.
Ancient beasts that are larger than life and capable of
untold destruction.
Will you be enough to stop them before it's too late?
As the world is torn apart, you and your friends must unite.
Is this just all Final Fantasy 7?
How much money did Square Enix pay for this slot?
Holy shit.
This is the longest trailer I've ever scene and stand
together yes one last time all right that's me
when jeff was like i'll do i'll give you the last slot for
free
he's like just please announce let me have it as the last
announcement bringing us this extended look at final finesse
7 revelation all right which one you guys want next nintendo
director's cannot wait to play it but matt i think we ended
the video too arie i hate to leave a story unfinished is
that right all right let's make a pull you better take a
look we'll do all right it's time for pay to win wow get the
cannon back online now let's draw my job john and then
Ahraz, their usual name.
John DiMaggio.
State of play.
Get your fingers ready.
Stretch your fingers, guys.
It's time.
Stretch your fingers.
Stay in the window.
Hi, I'm Mark Essen.
I'm the creative director and co-founder of Mess House.
You might know us for our 2014 hit, which is a fencing
tug-of-war game with flying worms.
Nidhogg is fun.
More recently, we came out with Wheel World, an open-world
bicycle racing game about saving the world.
I love making games.
I've been making games since I was probably 15 years old.
It's something I do for fun in addition to my job.
It is a fun game.
So at night, I knew it from Node.
I don't know if you guys remember Node Gaming, which used to
be like people who worked with Rocket Jump slash Blood
Dungeon was created.
Quarter Digital, they have their own gaming channel.
And like, I would always watch them play Nidhogg all the
time.
Blood Dungeon is a...
I used to... I love the No Channel back in the day.
Just standing on platforms, you're crawling on the sides of
platforms, you're hanging from the ceilings.
And we watched them play, like, Airsoft Airsoft shit, like,
IRL Trouble and Terrorist Town.
And...
What's it called?
Spyfall or whatever.
But yeah, Airsoft, TTT.
And I really missed like animation and just being able to
hand animate.
I know TTT was fun.
It was fun to just churn them out.
That's fun.
Lots and lots of silly I've never played Airsoft before.
And I think the game turned out really fun.
There's a handful of arenas to explore.
You'll unlock over 100 weapons.
It's like these other survivor games you've probably played
where you're kiting the enemies and they're sort of
following you in a big mass.
But in this game, you're in a maze as well.
maze with gravity it's really a game about routing how about
route find the optimal routes know which weapons work with
which other weapons all right who wins this oh this is going
really fast And the winner is!
Theta Play!
Bro, guys, are your fingers okay?
Are you...
Let's go!
It is likely impossible that you could guess what the next
game is.
Sony!
Should have logged in on your fifth phone!
Can't control 909 channel points.
My points!
They got the auto-clicker.
Hello, I'm Ravori.
Check the PC.
And I'm Mason Smith, also known as AirDors.
Check their PC.
They used an auto-clicker.
Rev.
Check their software.
Points well spent.
Unfortunately to the Nintendo Bros, their points didn't
matter.
Welcome to the real world.
Give me the Nintendo clickers.
You should have used an auto clicker.
Stop the count.
All right.
Stay to play.
I think this is the right one.
It would be a shame if I downloaded the wrong one.
All right.
Let me...
This...
any okay wait is there sound team for state of play because
i don't know how loud state of play is gonna be all right
here we go whoa
sound guy's like oh my god sorry sound guy was like i just
got into a deadlock game all right let's see guys i think
it's a little too loud i i think it was a little too loud
holy shit okay all right here we go oh wolverine you start
i'm marcus smith creative director for marvel's wolverine
today we're excited to debut a new look at the game to set
the stage wolverine is in a race against time to rescue a
group of kidnapped mutants before they're shipped off to
parts unknown by cybernetically trafficking no damn however
logan quickly discovers he isn't the only mutant attempting
to save them let's take a look come all right
lower it a bit more all right did the one that got away
oh is it saber tooth you know i just found out his name
isn't even Logan.
I don't even know what his first name actually is.
Like, his real name isn't even Logan.
Why the fuck did he name?
It's not.
I guess Logan is, Logan is just cooler, I guess.
What?
Dude, I just, I just found out like a month ago, because it
was on Twitter.
His name is James.
I mean, to be fair.
Just doesn't go as hard, you know?
Imagine your name.
I'm sorry Imagine your name is James is a little lame for
Wolverine.
I'm sorry
Rift to all James
That sound guys are better as a James.
Yeah, I know
All right, I lowered it a little bit bit more sound yeah
it looks fun I don't do want to play oh my god okay sorry
sorry sorry you freak us why is he muted
muted Oh, shit.
I've always wanted to play Spider-Man games, too.
There's so many games to play.
There you are, Red.
Yeah, Gene.
Is that you?
Don't worry.
You're not going anywhere.
I mean, that has to be Gene, right?
I feel like Gene's powers are like...
I don't know.
I feel like Gene's powers get retconned So or like she just
It's always something new Yeah Like her powers are all over
the place She doesn't have like consistent Powers, IMO
Because like If you look at all the different medias of
Gene, it's like Her powers are like It's all over the place.
I don't even know what her power scale is.
Jesus Christ I think that God's dead.
Like, the power scaling of her?
No.
No, if you see, like, animation versus movies versus games
and stuff versus comics, it's, like, I feel like it's, like,
very inconsistent.
It's a make-people-gay.
God, you can talk.
Thank you.
A hundred biddies.
But yeah, her scaling is weird.
I don't know her power scaling.
Alright, lower it a little bit more sound, guys.
Because, like, Wolverine, you know, claws and regeneration.
You know?
Sometimes she jumps really, really far.
But, like, Gene, I...
If you ever watched, like, some of the original animation,
like, not the original animation, What was it?
The one which were...
They did a lot of rotoscoping ones.
Not the classic, not the classic ones.
The really popular anime-esque, like...
Like, her only power back then was just telekinesis and
telepathy.
But, like, not, like, hardcore telekinesis, like, what we
just saw.
Yeah, and then she also falls unconscious a lot, too.
Wait, there's no X-Men in Wolverine?
What the fuck?
What is Xavier doing?
Is he just being a rich British boy?
Is he just being posh?
I don't know.
He's just in a wheelchair.
Bro, no, he's probably walking at that point.
It's because he can walk so he doesn't make the X-Men in an
alternate universe.
where he never became disabled.
Nope, yeah.
Let's get you guys out of here.
Are you a superhero?
Oh, God.
I'm sorry.
I didn't think I was going to get close-up.
What's your problem?
The close-up got me off guard, guys.
Wait, was that Deadpool?
What the fuck?
Oh, there's Sabretoop.
Oh, yeah, Sabretoop flies.
Sorry, I don't know why I thought he was redheaded.
For some reason, I thought Sabretoop was a redhead.
We hope you enjoyed that new look at Marvel's Wolverine.
This is a single-player action-adventure game featuring a
focused, story-driven experience that will send Logan on a
perilous journey across the globe, where more than innocent
mutant lives are at stake.
in this game mutants you guys okay you guys ever oh my god
why does he have so much screen time gray mystique and saber
tooth some folks can't wait to die we also showed you the
brutal combo it's fast fluid and visceral in the way that
only logan can deliver
of the PlayStation 5 consoles and we cannot wait for you to
get your hands on it when it launches September 15th, 2026.
We're also happy to ask that you can pre-order your copy
today.
That's so soon.
I thought it'd be coming in 2027.
Check out PlayStation blog for more information.
On behalf of everyone.
Is Gully here?
Thank you.
See you next time.
Where you can, yeah, if only, if only Wolverine was a battle
royale, then it would be perfect in fact if only not only
that if only i can extract somewhere after i save the other
mutants how would i extract guys where is my extraction
point a ton more to share with news and updates from both
playstation studios and third-party studios from around the
globe let's get right to it with the latest from our friends
at arc systemworks xdev oh i saw this one i saw the
announcement for that because everyone was freaking out i
love the art style of all of the extract the crocoa oh yeah
i was gonna say since we're talking about superheroes
okay i'm pausing this thank you playstation for letting me
pause it um a little bit of fun fact but um people are like
oh xav charles xavier he's not he's a really bad guy for
those who don't know like the the movies it's just because
like what's his name Picard, the guy who, oh my gosh, I
forgot, I always forget the actor's name, the guy who plays
Picard, the guy who plays, yeah, he's a massive asshole.
He is not a good guy.
Patrick Stewart, yeah.
Patrick Stewart and James McAvoy, um, in the movies, in the
live action movie, they make him like, because, you know,
they're like, he's in a wheelchair.
We can't make him an asshole.
Like, he's already disabled.
He can't walk.
So, like, they make him in the movies that they make him,
like you know they don't want to be like wow like he's an
asshole and he's in a wheelchair like so they try to make
him like um they try to make the character to be like he's a
really nice guy look he really cares about the mutants guys
he yeah we gotta make him really likable we gotta make him
an asshole in a wheelchair like in the movies so but if you
guys ever seen like some of like the cartoons and the comics
and every other media that's not the live action yes he's
apparently he has walked he has now been able to walk longer
than he has ever been in the wheelchair by the way and so
yes i'm called i'm gonna talk about the beam so one moment
during one of the cartoon in one of the episodes in one of
the cartoons yeah he's been he's been walking longer than he
has been in the wheelchair but in one of the episodes um he
got in a fight with magneto and then for those who don't
remember because like obviously now they i bet they reconded
it because it's like it's been so long since world war two
magneto is a holocaust survivor so he's he's like jewish and
he was he's like he will survive the holocaust so in one of
the episodes uh charles xavier did something called the
Holocaust beam where he sent a beam ray into Magneto's head
and to make him relive the trauma of the Holocaust.
And so Charles Xavier basically like gave him, like made
him, gave him PTSD and he what so that's pretty that's
really yeah
he didn't even need to do that by the way yeah he weaponized
his trauma so so so he's not a great guy like the Charles
Xavier the character outside of the live action movie is not
a great person he's he's a he's an like him in a wheelchair
does not exempt the fact that he is an asshole but they
didn't want to portray that in the live action movies so
obviously you know and he's like a like he's like actually a
fuck boy like I'll show you guys the gift it's actually
crazy oh yeah
here's wait what the fuck I didn't realize it was also in
the comic too wait what is this look at this guys it was
also in a comic there you go here's the animation for it
that stuff that's fucked up bro there it is there's the
holocaust theme that's an insane page it is it is actually
it's a canon event
The most strong is mutant power.
Yeah.
So, yeah.
He's an asshole.
He still is.
I think after he was able to walk, they were like, now we
can make him even more of a jackass.
Like, now he can be as, like, I guess, as much of a bitch as
he wants now that we can walk.
Yeah.
He does not mess around.
That's crazy.
Oh yeah, a little fun fact.
The little...
Oh yeah, I don't know.
Oh yeah, by the way, if anyone ever watched the newest
cartoon, what was it?
The X-Men...
Like, what was the newest animation called?
Um...
What was the newest...
X-Men 97?
Gambit gets cucked by Magneto.
If anyone watches the new...
Yeah, again?
What?
Yeah, there's a scene in there where Rogue and Magneto mix
out in front of Gambit.
Yeah.
Okay, maybe Magneto deserves that.
What on earth is going on?
So yeah, Rogue, like, slow dances with Magneto.
And then they start making out.
And then Gavin was just like, what the fuck?
Like, he's in front of him.
Actions are worth more.
For Mutant God.
Imagine, though.
To be fair, I will say, I will.
say imagine the mutant baby powers though like I I feel like
magnetic powers with with rogue with rogue powers the
genetics between the two makes like damn that's a strong-ass
baby versus like rogue and gambit powers like you know it's
like pretty OP
Oh yeah, Doom's team.
Let me show you why you should leave.
Think you're a genius, Doom?
Your works are mere trinkets.
My genius is endless.
And now my turn.
Oh, there he is.
Is the same voice actor from Rivals?
He sounds just like him.
This violence will solve nothing, Eric.
My dearest Aurora.
and kind shall rise.
Yeah, yeah, he sounds just like him.
I love the character design.
I love the goblin.
Okay, have you guys seen the, sorry, have you guys seen the
goblin memes after they announced goblin?
It was so funny.
It's like, come on, use wake up DI.
They'll never expect it.
Do it again.
They're never gonna expect wake up DI.
third time.
Do it.
I wish I had saved him.
It was so good.
Median wake up.
Toleep them.
You know you want to.
Where did they stick and expect a fifth toleep?
The mask calling for you.
You're still holding the grudge.
Currency ha time to stop laughing.
It's so good.
I love that those memes Oh, man the card one reminds me of
marvel versus capcon.
It's so similar to I love I love was was a carnage on marvel
versus capcon Or was it venom?
But like I it reminds me so much of Marvel versus capcon
Play style like how venom play like how carnage plays
Knights of Doom Destroyed Doesn't it though?
You my wrath The end is near I remember playing Venom a lot
Back then from Marvel vs.
Capcom Because I thought he was so cool Howard the Duck Oh
you can have it As an avatar
I see much from my atop the tree of tranquility yet there
are some outcomes that are uncertain even to me what game is
this not the two two two dragons oh raven twice told
throughout the green raven back
What is that?
Um, but, um...
Follow me, brave heroes.
The glade of dreams is...
I didn't grow up with Raymond, so like...
Um...
I didn't play Raymond games growing up, but I know, like, a
lot of people were, like, super hyped about it.
unfortunate thing about raymond um the unfortunate part is
that rabbit rabbits are more popular raymond itself and also
um and also like it's really hard to merchandise i remember
if you were saying like raymond is just not good then you
can't merchandise raymond you know you can't make
merchandise off of him because his his arms and legs are
literally not connected it's We had the floating limbs.
You know it's true.
People remember the rabbits.
More than Raymond.
Because they're minion-coded.
Or is this Dave the Diver?
I didn't play that game, but I heard it was really good.
Oh, it's not Dave the Diver, right?
Is it?
Oh, it's not.
Let's get it.
What's this?
Oh, it's a sequel?
Or a prequel?
You got shy.
You can't stop me and get sloppy to bear on them.
Gamba!
Instead of diving, we're fishing.
I never played data diving, but I know it was really...
I know people say it's really fun.
What's this?
Get it?
She's a cat.
Oh, wow, wow, wow.
What is Token Gaming?
Is this an extraction shoot?
I'm joking.
You are a yokai hunter.
I mean, it looks fun.
It looks cool.
I love the art style.
Oh
Okay, you need an internet for the online Oh, so it's on up
to three players Oh, it's a night ring I think so It's a
three-player game Death is only in the beginning It could be
yeah, I think it's night ring
Oh my god, they're so cool There's a lot of different
abilities too.
Yeah, Yokai Night Ring.
At least we'll get something Yokai like in America.
Shots fired.
Peep-a-peep.
Hi, everyone.
Oh, it's her!
It's her.
Did you miss me?
I'm missing you.
How long has it been since she first appeared?
Yeah, because she got famous off of one of the theme show.
Oh, she's making another yokai game.
Was it three, wasn't it really three years ago?
No, it was long in three years.
She really likes yokai.
Her first appearance when she was I'm trying to remember it
from the Game Awards.
Because she got famous because she was introducing a horror
game.
It wasn't Ghost Wire Tokyo, it was something else.
Was it?
No, that was not her first appearance, was it?
Was Ghost Wire really her first appearance?
Oh, it was!
Okay, yeah, she was really cute.
Everyone, she was so memorable.
Yeah, her first viral appearance because she was like super
cute.
That was a long time ago.
I like her style.
She gave a teaser.
for this game, right?
I remember, because everyone was like, I was, I remember, I
remember her last game awards appearance, or was this, I
remember it was, yeah, game awards appearance, she gave a
teaser for this, and everyone was like, what the fuck is
this?
Like, yeah, I remember, because like, I were like, I was
like, I don't know what this game is about, like, what is
this teaser about, like, yeah.
She's so cute, I'm sorry, I really, like, she's such a cute,
developer i
love how animated she looks she like she's like she's like
she's like so animated like cartoon you know hard woman to
track down she has still has passion and hope in her eyes
which is nice a lot of devs usually are dead inside tomb
raider miss croft i hear when it comes to retrieval worry
or money or making the world a better place what's up boobs
i mean this is a puzzle sorry it's about puzzles yes you
don't strike me as someone who walks past a locked door
without wondering what's behind it that too there's a reason
i can only trust you oh is it amazon game studios i didn't
even notice that i didn't see oh there's a dinosaur
I've never played any of the Tomb Raider games, by the way,
never in my life.
I didn't grow up with it, so I never played it.
Nope.
I just know all the memes.
Gotta say, I captured your good side.
I just know all the memes and references.
this legacy
of elantis what
is this so what was your favorite from today i like the
allison oh donoguing what did you like about it he's big and
loud i mean that's all the dinosaurs though they're all
pretty well not all of them but wait that's a fake we're out
of the fetus Where's the feathers?
Oh, shit.
Okay, sorry.
I shouldn't have complained about the feathers.
Imagine if that was the last thing you said to your dad.
Where are the feathers?
Oh, there's feathers.
There you go.
That's a real dinosaur.
I don't know if I can do this.
The feather dancers are not as cool, Tokey.
Where is my frog DNA?
There's always a choice.
The Lost Wild.
Wait, can I not shoot the dinosaur?
Oh, no.
Is this an alien?
Is this a Dino isolation incident?
I should be allowed to shoot the dinosaur.
That's a baby that is so dangerous just like throw the baby
to the side or something you're squishy don't land okay i
feel like it's more dangerous having the baby in your arms
like you're shaking the baby like also you're not supposed
to shake the baby question mark i
That guy's choked that baby a lot.
Oh,
that looks cool.
He has broke the neck.
What game was that?
Back in early 2023, S-Game first showed us Phantom Blade
Zero in passing at a hotel.
And we knew immediately that this game had incredible
potential.
Phantom Blade Zero.
dive coming later this summer oh we don't that's all we get
over to the sandworm infested sands of aracas in dune i
guess that's all we got in this i would like to know more
because that was all pre-rendered like i was like okay a
cinematic story filled with mystery and intrigue featuring
many of the characters from the books and movies find the
fremen wake the sleeper Yeah, it's just pre-rendered baby
shaking you will explore the vast open world of Arrakis I've
never done anything with Dune before.
I have never watched the movies.
I've never I don't know about Dune is the Fleshlight popcorn
bucket I'm sorry.
That's the only thing I know about Dune What oh shit all
right Because if I had to see it obviously you all have to
see it Dune popcorn for him.
Fuck it.
There we go.
If I have to see it, we all have to see it for those.
So, this is the Dune.
I'll give you guys a close-up too.
Let me save the close-up.
You can grab it on eBay for... How much for is it?
On eBay?
You can grab it on eBay for $400.
Jesus Christ.
It's not even, like, monopoly Canadian money $400 all right
here we go wait a close-up here so this is the dune popcorn
bucket so you guys get the picture right you guys get yeah
you guys see it right like I'm not the only one that sees
this right so that's like uh that's it but then you're like
that's not too Here's the close-up of it.
So it's like, you know...
Yeah, that's the only thing I know about Dune.
It's just this pop...
Wait a minute.
They're on something.
I should call it.
So yeah.
Anyway, you can get your very old...
dune popcorn bucket for 350 dollars right now how many of
you have bought this i wonder if there's like it tells you
how many has been sold 114 people have bought the dune
popcorn bucket guys guys
guys guys guys they have sold out through 114 they have sold
18.
Guys, it's the last one though.
You cannot.
Do you really want to miss out on the Dune popcorn bucket?
It's the last one.
Pursue the path of the Bene Gesserit, Swordmaster, Trooper,
or Mentai.
I'm about to make it a hundred and fifteen.
To brutal hand to hand combat.
In Dune Awakening, you can choose to play with your friends
or a I heard doing is good though, like the series
franchise, the story and everything, and just, you know,
just never got around to do it.
I feel like, yeah, sometimes I feel like it's just too late.
I missed out, you know, I missed out on the hype.
PS5 on September 22nd.
Pre-orders start today.
The fan favorite PS2 classic Dynasty Warriors 3 is getting
remastered for PS5.
Dynasty Warriors 3.
Yeah!
Sorry, I just clicked in my head what it was.
I was like, oh my god, I clicked in my head.
I was like, yeah!
Sorry, that was lagged.
I had a brain lag there.
My donkey core!
Let's go, donkey slav!
I'm ready!
There we go.
Now I'm playing this game all the way to this.
the end actually i should and my manager is gonna be so mad
at me i fucking love oh my god that's like one of the best
ones too later this year pre-orders oh it's not like the oh
my god the story mode is so good too i love the story mode
for dynasty i like 100 complete it all like i each character
had its own unique story i love that i missed the old
dynasty warriors because each
Cinematic and story that it followed.
Like, maybe the missions are the same, but, like, they would
follow their own storyline for it, and it was so good.
So I would play, like, every character just to, like, see,
like, each new story that goes on.
And then you can change the story.
Like, you can change the events and stuff, and you win or
lose.
Because, you know, they're like, oh, this character was
supposed to win, but you play the character, and you win the
battle, the story changes.
Including endgame, all with full cross-border.
play and cross save.
Dynasty Warriors, I think three and four.
Dynasty Warriors 4 was also good, I think.
Let me look, look at which one was four.
Yeah, Dynasty Warriors 4 was good.
I played four.
What was five?
I need to look at the cover art.
Five was okay.
It was art.
Five.
Five was, I think it was like, when was it when it started
getting bad?
I'm trying to remember when it was.
3, 4, 5, 6 Oh, Oni Motion!
I think I'm looking forward to that too Yeah That castle on
the mountain 3, 4, 5 I remember 5 was pretty good too 3 was
a classic Prepare yourself No ordinary game I can move like
that I like the demo too This area was designed to welcome
visitors The castle was I must be terribly cautious, but I
feel like I did play the demo.
Okay.
The only thing was what's the word called?
I remember ah, what was what's the word?
Uh, I'm trying to remember how I'm trying to remember the
word for this, but you know how like Onimusha was like a
cult fall.
It had like a little bit of like How what's it called where
it was like Like some weird shit like you know how we had
like cyborg courses and stuff and like what's the word for
it's very uh not niche but the story was a little bit like
weird as hell with a little bit of like weird shit in there
with like not I'm not saying call it following niche it was
the word for it and I feel like Onimush camp it was very
campy yes the original Onimusha or Onimusha oh fucking I can
always the only Onimusha games were very very campy um
because there was a lot of weird ass shit in there because
that's what I loved about Onimusha uh because I for some
reason I don't know why I keep saying Onimushu um yeah with
the fucking Mecca shit like randomly in places so the only
thing I'm like a little bit worried about for the newest
Onimusha game is that we're not gonna have the weird shit
that's that's the only thing I'm worried I don't I'm worried
that It's not gonna be as campy as it was.
Because it looks a little serious.
You know?
It looks a little more serious.
Because the original Onimusha games were so fucking campy.
Will you swap the sword for a trial?
Like hell I will.
And there were some funny, like, you know, funny lines and
stuff.
Like even Onimusha 1 was like pretty silly with the
With like the lines With the writing and scripts I've chosen
to trust him It looks good though I feel a lot I think I was
like one of the few streamers that have played the original
trilogy Like well I watched my dad play the original trilogy
So I hold a lot of, like, nostalgia over Onimusha.
The demo is fun.
The demo was hard.
The last boss fight was hard in the demo.
I have streamed Onimusha 1 and 2.
I haven't streamed 3 yet.
Did I stream 3?
I think I streamed 1 and 2.
I'm pretty sure I didn't stream 3 yet.
We can't wait to get our hands on Onimusha way of the sword
this September.
But you won't have to wait long to try it yourself.
from the Onimusha 2.
I know I remember playing another September game.
Yeah, I only did one and two.
I was like, I'm pretty sure I didn't play three on stream.
Yeah, I think when Onimush...
Oh, the funny thing is...
I think...
Oh, I remembered.
When Onimusha 2 remake came out, I was one of the few
streamers, like a few of the bigger streamers that played
Onimusha 2.
Because I remembered when Onimusha 2 came up, Stellar Blade
came out at the same time.
When it was Stellar Blade, it was like Sandland.
No, it was Sandland.
Never mind.
It was like a Sandland scenario.
It was, I remember, I remember another big game came out
around the time when Onimusha 2 remake came out.
But yeah, it was similar to Sandland where Sandland came
out.
Nobody was really playing Sandland other than me.
Because Stellar Blade came out around the same time as
Sandland.
so I was like one of the few big streamers that was playing
Sandland and everyone else was playing Stellar Blade and
that's why I never played Stellar Blade because I was
playing Sandland and Onimusha 2 I remember it was something
similar a big game came out I just don't remember what game
it was um but a big game came out around the same time as
Onimusha 2 and I was one of the few big streamers that was
playing Onimusha 2 because I like Onimusha 2 uh because I
love the Onimusha series so I was like super hyped about it
and so and then I got sent a PR package because I was played
Onimusha.
And they were reached out to me and be like, can we send you
some Onimusha merch?
I was like, fuck yeah!
So I also got a PR package from it.
Turn it to Capcom.
Same with Sandland.
I got a PR package from Sandland because they were happy
that I streamed it.
And I was like, I like the game.
I really like it.
I remember reading the one shot, the Sandland one shot.
What's this?
oh this is the silent hill the new silent hill game almost
forgot about they showed this before i think we saw like 800
trailers for this game
oh my god it's so like the off-tune shit is throwing me off
i think it i think it's not scary right now because the sun
is out you guys aren't scared yet because they're like the
sun is out right now.
We're not in... Oh, there we go!
Now we're in Silent Hill.
There it is.
It's more silent and more hilly.
Oh, shit.
That's your inner demons?
A naked man?
Back in our day.
Our male protagonist.
We're horny for nerds.
Not a sexy nurse can't catch me cave thoughts.
He's having gay thoughts right now.
It's like I'm wearing nothing at all.
Nothing at all.
We will storm from the sea and take the capital back from
our enemy.
Where's my sexy male nurse?
Why aren't you looking at this?
Oh, it's East Combat.
Yeah.
Some sort of symbol that inspires hope.
We will be in visual range of the land battleship soon.
That's giant.
Never played East Combat before.
Where's wings when you actually need him?
All units return to base.
It's like Porsa before play nerds.
That's where the wings of Thieve comes in.
The legendary savior.
Didi wants the legendary savior to get as much publicity as
possible.
No, it's...
No, it's playing Metal Gear.
We're going to be one zone.
All aircrafts pull out.
Sorry, Rex.
You stay put, Choco.
It's Metal Gear for playing there.
Wait, there's story in this?
Oh.
I thought it was just planes Guys, I've never played ace
combat before.
I just thought it was just planes.
I thought it's like world of tanks, but it's like world of
planes Oh, it's so crazy
We've got a leak Well now I know
There is a world of planes go take what you're hearing about
is world of tanks World of Tanks is like great Shadow
Legends, but for planes.
I remember when every YouTube video was sponsored by World
of Tanks.
It was a great Shadow Legends for Tanks.
Okay, ice cream.
After this trailer, I'm going to get my...
I have a cotton candy Dairy Queen Blizzard in the freezer.
I need some ice cream right now.
I don't know why.
think of ice cream did you know I know kind of aces whoa
it's cotton candy cotton candy Blizzard from Derrick Queen I
kept it in the fridge that's good I like it I have a taste
bud of a child that's right That's fucking right
All right, we're gonna pause this I'm gonna grab my ice
cream real quick guys, I'll be right back
All right, I'm back I do have a pre-cooked meal I don't eat
pre-cooked meals all day every day Just because I always get
bored of the I get bored of the variety So I just do have a
pre-cooked meal that I eat today just to fill up my stomach
a little bit It's a small one I won't get a real meal later,
so I'll let my ice cream melt And then I'll continue
watching Okay, something light, it's a salad A pasta salad
And then I'll eat, I'll have Because I don't want to eat ice
cream while eating an actual meal You know Okay so weird
haha what's this
this hot wheels with like DSL, DSLR on imagine hot wheels
reimagined
what the fuck it was not real my immersion yep roll playback
stuck man oh shit oh what
Oh, so you recreate, like, scenes from movies, right?
That's cool.
I think I heard about...
Yeah, I saw Twitter about it that they have Back to the
Future stuns.
And that's a little fucked because someone actually got
paralyzed because of a Back to the Future stun.
Because of an exact Back to the Future car stun.
I wonder if that's in it.
Yeah, there's a specific scene in Back to Feature.
They kept the take, by the way.
Um, they kept the take.
Oh my god, I should not be eating while watching this, but
whatever.
It's in the film.
I don't remember which scene it was.
Um, but, um, it's...
Someone got, like, paralyzed from one of the scenes.
And it was, like, a one-take thing.
Surprisingly lively for someone who just came out of a coma.
If you want to survive...
We've got to hustle.
What the fuck is this?
You fell from the moon.
I will help you, but you must not go there.
That was cool.
I'll take my chances.
All up, but the zombie?
Turns out I'm a lucky man.
Rummy's outing.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, it's the babies!
I remember!
We saw this trailer before.
There's a creepy baby trailer, remember?
From the Game Awards?
Ew.
I was also eating when we watched that trailer.
Wow, it's like, I never left.
I remember I was also eating.
Something is coming.
This is another.
Oh, it's another control trailer.
It felt like an earthquake.
But it was just a paperclip.
Falling off a desk.
The tiniest tremor before the main event.
I know what they put you through.
You never had a chance.
I don't think I could ever finish control of it, guys.
There's so much reading.
Two days before the lockdown fell, an uncategorized
resident.
It would have been nice if she read out the readings, but
there was so many stuff there, A.
You are only shot at survival.
You are not FVC.
Why have you just not read the Lord?
You know why
You don't want to open that can of worms
Who are you today
Hey Dylan we're gonna have a lot of fun together And then
you had too much fun.
Oh,
okay.
Oh, marathon.
Hey, Destiny players.
Are you enjoying marathon?
Did you enjoy marathons for your weekend?
No.
It was stupid.
Okay.
And vast.
Secrets.
Buried in shining.
In the graves.
I cried out in my sleep.
A war leaf.
Oh damn.
Is it Marathon in the dark?
It's a little scary.
It definitely is a little scary when it's in the dark.
But also I can't see anything.
But also, I would like to be able to see my video game.
I enjoyed playing Marathon with friends when I was playing
with Shreveport and Gully in bed.
That was fun.
But that was just me.
It was because me and Gully were rage baiting Shreveport.
I think that's what made it more fun if we were just rage
baiting him.
Cutthroat World of Marathon expands today with its second
season, Night Ball.
And if you haven't checked out Marathon yet, Bungie
announced an open trial period for the launch of season two.
You'll also be able to pick up Marathon at a discount.
Now, let's take a look at what's coming soon to PlayStation
Plus.
Up first, a beloved fantasy world is finally coming to
PlayStation for the first time.
RuneScape Dragon Wilds is an open world survival game where
you rise from survivor to dragon slayer.
Play solo or with friends as you explore Ashenfall.
I have beautiful and dangerous new frontier in the runescape
universe.
Where power is earned and every action deepens your mastery.
Ice Queen!
Yay!
With magic at your command, you cross deadly terrain, mass
forage and seconds.
It's a small one.
Uncover hidden paths and outmatch brutal monsters.
I don't have a lot of ice cream.
I had like half an ice cream.
I have a small blizzard cup.
Because I finished half and I was like, before.
Melee and ranged combat.
and push deeper into uncharted regions of Gilinor.
Build a home together, farm the land, and fish the water.
It's a small, it's a small, I order like a small three cook
meals.
Cause it's three meals, um, I have like, it's like,
sometimes it's like two or three peak cook meals a day.
So like I order small portions just cause like, you know, if
I'm eating three meals, then I'd rather have it in like
super small.
Coming to the classics catalog over the next few months.
dinner in june battle colorful enemies with musical
instruments and guitar room man one of the most stylish
rhythm games from the ps2 era i was like what game is this
it reminds me of like para para in july psyops the mindgate
conspiracy joins the classics catalog this ps2 action
adventure mixes running gun gameplay with psychic powers
Whoa.
And finally, Onimusha Dawn of Dreams, a Capcom classic from
2006.
I've never seen this one.
I've never seen this Onimusha game before.
Why is it all in Japanese?
Is there now an English port of it?
I've never seen this one before.
Yeah, is it Japan only?
Oh, it's a Japan exclusive.
Yeah, I was gonna say I've never seen that game before.
island haunted by dark stories our goal confront the evil
corrupting paradise this is dead true international
why is this come on let's get a photo together do a flip he
did a flip rotated on that one a for effort dude i never
guessed this game dead island no one know this guy this is
how where did he come from yeah oh you two haven't met yet
right sebastian how about looking out for you roland
whenever you're ready this facility has been shut down for
decades i'm investigating I'm tall until now.
Oh.
This feels so cabin in the woods.
No, it feels so.
Oh, where's it called?
Are you out there?
Oh, shit.
Fuck.
Until dawn, yeah.
It feels so untow- until dawn, like.
Right.
I have a bad feeling.
Let's get rid of that.
Take a deep breath.
Fuck.
Which way?
The steady.
The mine.
We're going to have to jump.
There's rocks down there.
Okay.
Oh, it is.
It is until I'll die.
Sorry.
I feel like you should be able to see a rock there before
you jump.
Oh, it is until death.
Yeah, I was going to say it didn't.
Nazi a giant fucking rock it is oh my gosh I was like this
feels so cab in the woods and it clicked in my head until
dawn I was like because until dawn was like creative
director of fire sprite games and I hope you enjoyed the
first look at our brand new that's crazy in unfil dawn 2 a
successful crew of ghost hunters who fake all the best
content come face to face with real horrors for the very
first time whenever you're ready I was also gonna say that
girl looked like the girl from zeroed clock but i didn't
want to say it but i was like this feels so until dawn like
but also like i didn't want to say until dawn because the
graphics look a little bit more cartoony than until dawn
having just signed a deal with a major tv like they visit i
felt like the motion capture for it is like less realistic
versus until dawn centuries old and hungry for vengeance
we're looking forward to sharing more details about this
yeah it looks more blast with you Thank you.
Yeah, until Dodd had more realistic, like, features.
Now, we have one more game to show, and it is something
special.
This is a brand new title debuting with more than 20 minutes
of uninterrupted gameplay.
So turn up the volume, sit back, and enjoy.
Finish my ice cream.
I want more, but I can't have more.
Oh my god, I forgot to tell you guys.
I bought a choco-bubu.
I was walking around.
Because I wanted to go out to grab food.
And then I went to a store.
And they were selling a choco-bubu.
And you're wondering, what is a choco-bubu?
I don't think it's licensed.
I'm pretty sure it is definitely not legal.
But it's a chocolate la-bubu.
buy chocolate chocolate la booboo let me see if i can look
it up a chocolate booboo i bought the green one oh yeah i am
pretty sure these are not licensed i i'm pretty sure these
are definitely not they do not look like something that is
licensed buy the actual booboo company but anyway I bought a
choco booboo I don't think it's gonna taste good but I just
thought it was funny and I wanted to try it up here this is
not my picture I got it from Google but look it's a choco
booboo look I got the green one it's the choco boo boo do
buy chocolate look at that the choco boo boo i got the green
one down there i bought it today wait i wouldn't grab it i
don't even know how much i paid i just bought it
that's right this is my disposable income It's a lot smaller
than you think it is.
It's actually, like, the size of an...
Of an...
Like, it's, like, a little bit shorter than an iPhone Pro or
whatever.
I'll try it right now while I play this video.
Try my Choco Boo Boo.
This will be the first time I've ever had Dubai Chocolate,
by the way.
For my Choco Boo Boo.
you know
the reason why dubai chocolate was invented was so people
would stop looking up the real definition of dubai chocolate
so because they wanted to like clean their image so they
invented dubai chocolate that's why dubai chocolate became a
thing find your way home you are free
I recognize those tattoos anywhere
Oh there they are burning her body
Yoki can't have my Choco boo boo Wait guys I'm sorry I do
have to pause this I have to I have to feed him real quick
Dad no No I'm gonna feed you I was I need to take a picture
of my chocoboo-boo.
Here.
I'll show you guys a picture of my chocoboo-boo.
It's not.
Okay, it's just meat.
I will say it is definitely just mediocre.
It's not.
Wait.
Why?
No.
Okay, wait.
Give me a sec.
Give me a, give me, give me two minutes.
two minutes that's all I ask I don't ask for much I'm asking
for two minutes and I'll give you your food here you go
you must be like that's not too bad
what's my phone
is it any of this
There you go.
That's my leg!
I hope you're back.
I'm afraid of.
I'm back.
Do you like my choco boo boo?
I feel like... I feel like Twitch streams, all the crazy
shit happens on my Twitch streams.
Alright.
Back to God of War.
Oh, it's the mom!
We're playing as the mom now.
I remember people were talking about it.
I felt like that was already spoiled.
Like people were saying that the new game was going to be
based off the mom.
Like the leaks for it.
You know?
Yeah, now we're playing mom of boy.
Like it was going to be based.
Oh wait, not her.
It was going to be based off of the other, the new wife.
Not her.
I remember now.
People were gonna say like the new game was either gonna be
a based off of the old mom or the new mom.
Yeah, Freya.
I remember it now.
Yeah.
So because like the new game wasn't gonna be based off of
Kratos.
Yay.
Mama boy.
Either bite of the chocolate boo-boo.
If you're in heaven.
I didn't remember her name either, I'm sorry.
They're starting on the path.
It's just...
I didn't get to say goodbye.
Yeah, we never knew how she died.
She just turned dead.
This definitely isn't the light of Alphine.
I don't think she's in heaven, guys.
So why would there be a whole game about her if she was in
heaven?
Think about it.
What?
Oh shit!
Oh no, that sword's not as cool.
Oh shit, you can parry.
Okay, that's cool though.
I will say the sword's not cool, but that's cool.
The air combo, yeah.
Yeah, we're double-made crying now.
That's double-made cry.
I like that we're giving gameplay trailer.
New cat.
I think
That's a big cat, guys.
Yeah, the weird cat is back.
He just took someone's arm, right?
I'm too fair.
He is dead.
I guess I'll find my own way from here.
Like, where is she?
Like, is she in hell?
Is she in purgatory?
He burned her.
It's not possible.
Yeah.
It's tough.
I don't even think it's Fahala But way back you're dead girl
He fucking they burned your fucking body Like what do you
mean You're like literally we saw ashes Whoa we saw ashes
blowed off Oh shit yeah that sword fucking sucked anyway I'm
assuming this is like the first 15 like minutes of like the
first 10 minute gameplay which is very oh shit wait is this
Egypt we're in Egypt imagine your body got burned so hard
that you're just in Egypt now like
What the fuck?
Oh!
Not the dog!
What the fuck?
Oh!
Oh, they're burning again!
The whole world only has cats and dogs.
They're just, sometimes they're smaller cats, and sometimes
they're smaller dogs.
They're big dogs or small cats.
Is that like a...
What mythology?
That is not Norse.
Is that Chinese mythology?
A Mongolian?
Yeah, I was gonna say it.
This book's very Asian.
Mongolian.
Yeah, I was gonna say it's Mongolian.
Oh, it's a Mongolian war god.
Okay.
No, that's Egypt.
Wait, why are they working together?
Oh my god.
Cross-breeding.
They're mixing the gods now?
Oh, so cute.
Ah, it's...
Another mask.
It's a God of War.
It's like, it's a God conference right now.
This is important to you.
I wonder.
Like, God Con.
It's God Con, guys.
Oh, shit.
What was the thing on your hand?
He touched me again.
And I swear.
I will kill you.
Yeah, but Luffy wasn't really a god, though.
I can show you.
You can't keep me here.
Yeah, she was just a...
She was a frost giant.
Gateway is closed.
There is no escape.
Resisting truth.
Will only make this more pain.
Kiss.
Oh?
What's that?
Sekhmet.
No.
Bexie.
I will handle that problem.
It's great that they all spoke English though.
It's great that English is the universal language.
For the gods.
Oh my god.
We're gonna...
When will Jesus show up, guys?
But...
See, now that's a cat.
That was nice of them, yeah.
We're at GodCon.
So many cubes today.
Okay.
I think they're gone.
Oh my god!
Jack Quaid!
It's the cube!
He motion captured this, guys.
different you're a cube talking You know what it doesn't
matter.
How do we get out or healy?
Yeah, yeah, we've tried this guy motion captured for a cube
And you're a talking sword.
I'm not the sword.
I'm the ribbons obviously and my name is rude the cube is
frank I'm trying so I can find the picture again.
I thought I was so fucking funny.
He did not have to do that here there was no reason for him
to motion capture as this he could have just been voice
acting holding something back this isn't working for
those who never seen it before sorry where are we anyway
afterlife of the gods just remember oh it's the afterlife of
gods it is heaven slash hell Great.
Wait, I'll show up when you see a picture of him.
All right.
Your boss, Frank.
This is him.
This was him.
Just this is him.
That's his.
That's why you're trapped.
This is him.
He did this.
You made that big explosion happen, right?
My magic is wrong here.
Boy, UV.
I thought you were joking.
We all want that.
The emotion captured a cube.
Faye, you need to accept it.
All of it.
You're dead.
How?
How do I accept that?
Simple.
Focus.
You're here.
Be here.
Oi, cubie.
You know what's crazy?
What if I need to be somewhere else?
Kratos and his...
His...
and her son were like, don't worry.
She, that's looking crazy.
In the God of War games, they're like, she's in a better
place now.
Boy, don't worry.
She's out there looking out for us.
And then she's literally in like God hell.
That's it.
What were you taking on?
They're like, don't worry, boy.
She's at peace.
Like, mom's looking, mom's looking down on us right now,
right?
You're like, yeah.
My mom is supporting.
Just to find out she's a god hell fighting for her fucking
life.
Oh, Kratos.
Oh?
It's not real.
It's not even God.
Who invited her to god hell?
Wait, you're right.
I wonder when we...
When this game comes out, we could just skip the first 20
minutes of the...
Like, did you watch the trailer and the state of play?
If, yes, do you want us to skip the game to the next 20
minutes?
Like...
Oh my god, that's the motion capture!
It made him...
How do I know I can trust her?
I'll give it back I promise oh there's even the sword talks
I'm sorry I hope when I swing the sword she doesn't yap I
think I'm sorry the ribbon is the ribbon I just don't want
it to yap too much when I'm swinging the ribbon yeah
swinging the sword no I know I know it was the ribbon I just
you know
I just think it's a little annoying If she starts yapping
while I'm swinging the sword I mean sick Oh yeah, oh no All
the gods that Kratos killed Wait, you're right I don't need
help That's so true Oh, that's the motion capture guys He
did all his stunts guys He He's like, please jump really
We're like, here's a trampoline.
Start jumping on it.
Oscar worthy.
PQ performance.
He could just do that.
How the fuck did she die?
What if it's like she just died of cancer or something?
Because I was like, no.
I was like, how the fuck did she die?
Like, it's like, sorry.
she contracted like she died to illness yeah come on no I
got a promise to keep fine but lady that sword it's more
than you think it is she got COVID yeah that's why she's not
a Valhalla maybe that's why she's not a Valhalla I already I
will kill you Did she die them?
Oh, nice.
What's that disease?
Where it was, like, so bad that your lungs start shutting
down.
But now that we have vaccines, like, it got eradicated.
What was that one?
Not like.
Polio!
What if she got polio, guys?
That's why she's not in Bahala.
Back scenes weren't invented back then.
Oh wait, oh wait, not polio, sorry.
TB, tuberculosis?
You're scared of this sword?
I fear nothing.
Oh shit.
Also, that's crazy.
The Egyptian goddess was like, none of the...
None of the Egypt gods were as hot as my Mongolian god
boyfriend.
It doesn't hit us hard, the god mixing, you know?
To be fair, he's fucking jacked.
He's literally on fire.
Wow, I would have never known what game this is gonna be.
Oh my god.
It was a god of war game this entire time.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
Who could have known?
No way.
All right, let me go while this is playing.
I go to the down.
the last one.
Nintendo Direct.
We were all so surprised.
This one?
10 days ago.
Plus Nintendo Treehouse Live.
What?
Oh, we don't need to look at Nintendo Treehouse, right?
Actually, fuck it.
Let's just... I'll just download it all.
Just the Direct.
There's a uk version that just has the direct but then like
i'm worried that i don't know if it's like oh wait no there
it is never mind wait no this is a year ago yeah whatever
i'll just download the direct itself uh i
just don't know if it's like any different you know
playstation i'm downloading right now i'm it's queued for
processing I and it looks pretty I'm I'm interested in the
lore you know it's like yeah I I just thought it was funny
like uh she was like she was like yeah I want a real god I
want a magoly god but yeah the um the it looks pretty it
looks I don't know it looks fun it reminds me of the other
god of war games so yeah she likes her men buff so the
premise is interesting i'm curious why she's in god hell
because like i said in ragnarok and uh the other god what
was the god of war what was it called or god of war and god
of war ragnarok you know kratos and their son i forgot
arteus Yeah, Arteus, they were all both like, man, you know,
they were saying that she's in a better place now and that
don't worry, she's like, don't worry, she's watching, she's
watching over us and like mom will be proud, etc, etc.
Just for us to find out she's like fighting her own fucking
demons at the same time.
Like, don't worry, mom's in heaven now.
so did not expect that i did not expect to see that you know
she's not having she's not she's technically not in a better
place uh and that you know she might be going through it all
right let's go we're downloading at the moment it will be
ready in minute and we'll be ready
we I'm gonna hydrate real more a bit more
alright I'm so I did not really when I said I'm gonna watch
I'm glad we watched the Xbox one before I'm you know good
thing we watched the Xbox Box one before today.
I am slowly dying.
I'm just like, it would be.
It might be a little, it might, it might be a little too
long.
It might be.
I like the Xbox showcase.
They show Spyro.
I was really happy about that.
I think my own, like I said, my only issue regarding the
Spyro game was I'm worried that, because it is a, uh, it is
a uh sorry sorry my mind blanked out there it is a new game
from the studio they're not remaking a game i'm just worried
it's not gonna be as good uh so i i hope that i'm wrong
honestly i do hope i'm wrong like the graphics look amazing
but uh it reminded me a lot about spiral like the the newer
spiral games that weren't made by it was insomnia right
insomnia made spiral so it rem it made it i don't know it
just didn't look like it just it it looked like spiral 4.
and spiral 4 was pretty ass it reminded me of spiral 4 and 5
and i was not a fan of like those games so i'm just hoping
that i'm wrong because the small amount of gameplay we saw
reminded me of that versus the original spiral
i crash four was all right it was all right i think it was
just something about crash one to three maybe that like like
i crash four was okay for me i just didn't think it was like
great i think it was like oh it was like best crash game
i've ever played i think the original obviously the original
like two and three was one of my favorite was it you know
crash one was a crash three that's my favorite or crash
crash two was my favorite crash two was my favorite game out
of all the crashes um um envy they gave for the for the
donation thank you thank you if you don't want to watch the
whole features game show i do recommend the exodus trailer
from that it's a spiritual successor to mass effect made by
a bunch of devs who made mass effect and the other bioware
games Did they do a trailer for it before in another
showcase?
I was thinking about if I should do a future game showcase,
but I felt like a lot of the games were already announced.
So I don't know if there's new trailers in game shows.
Yeah, I know.
I remember, like, Exodus is familiar.
So that's why I was like, oh, no, wait.
Crash 3 is my favorite.
Sorry.
I'm looking at that.
Oh, I don't know.
actually two and three are tied two and three are time so
i'm looking at the box art so i'm like looking wait actually
do i like three or two more all right i like three more
actually no three is my favorite three crash three is my
favorite i was like at first it was like tied but then i I
remember the...
I really liked...
I really liked the...
Like, the Crash's sister.
The riding the...
Yes, the tiger!
I love the tiger ones.
I love the tiger levels.
They're really fun.
Yeah, I was thinking about it.
I was thinking about the tiger levels.
I really enjoyed the tiger levels.
And the Crash...
I think the Crash 3 bosses...
were more fun.
Yeah, so Crash 3 was my favorite.
I think Crash 3 bosses were more fun than Crash 2 bosses.
Where Spyro was my favorite.
I think Spyro 3 was my favorite just from collecting the
eggs.
I really liked collecting the eggs.
Like all the mini games.
I liked it.
Mini games didn't feel like painful.
So I really enjoyed collecting the little eggs.
Alright.
it's done last showcase
all right here we go
see all right i have downloaded the last one i don't know
sound guide all right last sound guy one last showcase sound
guy last showcase anyone alive before we begin anyone alive
for the last one
one minute I'm playing
I'm skipping oh shit I should not have skipped I didn't
realize I was gameplay trailer I thought that was a timer
why was that it looks like a timer
Don't be so hasty.
I went too far.
Hello, everyone.
I'm Yoshiaki Koizumi, and I'll be your guide for today's
Nintendo Direct.
First, here's a game that's coming to the Nintendo Switch
system.
Please, take a look at this.
there should be like a fucking 15 minute timer hello hello
my name is lol miss reads and I'm known for my reading lol
and more beep I'm here today to help show you oh new rhythm
heaven game I
never play rhythm heaven like rhythm heaven in general I
know the music is like class like you know they're all
classic but I think I just don't have rhythm.
That's why I just don't have rhythm.
So I've never played these games also because I didn't grow
in Nintendo games
Never played wireware game is pretty simple Like I said, I
didn't grow in Nintendo stuff press the correct button.
That's all there is to it But it's not always the same
rhythm Listen carefully to the beat So bad at that find your
flow And you'll be able to feel the rhythm.
How do you know when...
Two, three, four, now.
Okay.
Two, three, now.
Two, now.
Yeah.
Over 80 all new rhythm games are included.
Ooh, 80 new games?
As you play through the game, you can unlock different
modes.
For example...
I didn't grow up with Zelda.
I didn't grow up with, like I said, The only Nintendo game I
grew up with was literally anything that was on the Game Boy
console, like the Game Boy, Game Boy Advance, great DS.
And use the magical power of rhythm to beat monsters.
What were all the Game Boys?
It was Game Boy, Game Boy Advance, and one more.
Does I remember what the other one was called?
Oh, it's just Game Boy Advance and Game Boy.
Game Boy SP.
Yeah.
Oh my god, I forgot about SP.
What spells will strike a chord against the...
Okay, I will say, I'm not a fan of the...
I'm not a fan of the AI voice.
It sort of throws me off.
Enjoy all of this while playing solo.
Oh, yeah, Game Boy Color.
I had one too.
Yeah, I had all the Game Boys.
Yeah, I'm not a fan of the AI voices.
Up to four players can enjoy dedicated rhythm games.
Lo misreads, I'm sorry.
I need you to stop talking.
I know it's like the Nintendo, the memes from the Tomodachi
life, but I just feel like it doesn't work yet.
Oh, there's multiplayer now.
Oh, wait, that's fun.
Yeah, I like that.
I'm gonna get absolutely destroyed.
With them, heaven grew.
That's cool!
I like that it's multiplayer.
That was Rhythm Heaven Groove for Nintendo Switch.
This is gonna be intense.
People are gonna go so hard.
Nintendo Switch 2 System.
Please wait just a little longer for its release.
I think I only had...
Oh wait, yeah, oh wait, no, I did.
I did have a Game Boy.
Including some games that will also be available on Nintendo
Switch.
Let's begin with some headlines.
Master the way of the sword.
We saw this.
Onimusha.
Yeah, we saw Onimusha.
A new entry in the sword play action series is slashing on
the Nintendo Switch 2.
I don't know if people will be playing Onimusha on the
Nintendo Switch.
It's been overrun by monsters known as Genma.
Now, Miyamoto Musashi must prove himself beyond measure.
No, not.
Deflect.
And the powerful counter attack, EZ.
It's cool that they're showing us the moves I'll never do so
you guys can at least experience it in some way.
So at least you guys can see it.
You can even use Joy-Con 2 motion controls to intuitively
slay Ganon.
Okay, wait, that's fun.
That's funny.
You can pretend you actually have the sword.
I don't think that.
That's cool.
You can start.
You can larp about it.
You can larp it.
Immersed yourselves.
Your unwritten epic begins.
Dragon's Dogma 2.
Dark Arisen is heading to Nintendo Switch 2.
Now I'm using the actual definition of larping.
See, that's what LARPing actually means, guys.
To all you zoomers out there, that's the real meaning of
LARP.
Explore the new land of Norgon.
Seek out spoils.
Then appraise them to reveal new weapons, armor, or skills.
Another September game.
Yeah, because they don't want to compete with Transsef Auto.
This single-player action RPG adventure.
Noon!
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Skilled in spell casting choose the vocation that fits your
play style plus you can leave a dragon's dogma Custom
companions who act on their own what game?
Which game was it with the big-titty witch girl?
Is that also dragon's dogma?
Key to victory In a world between dark and light in bark on
the adventure and tell a tale.
Oh, sorry.
I got them both confused because they both had dragon in it
Dragon's Dogma 2.
No, it's the big boobs witch girl.
And then a big buff-ass woman and then a dwarf.
That's all I could remember from the characters.
I don't remember it because everyone was like gooning over
the big buff-ass woman and then the big titty witch girl.
Now, turn deep on her mission to save humanity and reclaim
the planet.
And it's the only reason why I remember that game.
Then find your opening and strike.
Defeat enemies to acquire new skills.
Then strategically deploy them to fit the situation.
Can you save humanity and reclaim Earth for humankind?
Stellar Blade launches on the Nintendo Switch 2 next year.
And it was Stellar Blade.
Blast off in the two-player co-op adventure.
Oh, wait, I saw it was the...
Protect your home.
It was just like, it takes two, but like...
It's basically, it's take two, but with nostalgia.
Activate devices in time with the beat.
Escape from incoming enemies.
The animation looks really cute.
I wonder if it's 2D or 3D.
Because you can make 3D models look 2D now.
Locally or online using GameShare.
Work together and overcome the crisis of the cosmos.
Orbital's launches exclusively on the Nintendo Switch 2
system September 3rd.
Pre-orders begin later today on Nintendo eShop.
Oh, there's Rayman Legends.
Reimagining of Rayman Legends.
Not a lot of new announcements yet.
It's up to Rayman and his friends to leap and lie.
And launch their way through charming and colorful worlds.
Ride dragons across realms.
dive into four new musical stages and enjoy more added
content up to four players can go out on a limb in local
co-op we saw all this already also play a revamped version
of come foot using game share locally or online Rayman
legends retold a throwback that's the real game right there
that's the real game football set off through a peaceful
world brimming with challenges puzzles and lots of things to
discover
enjoy the sights and sounds as you work together to find
your way around use all sorts of tools i don't need to go
outside i can just play this game and figure out new methods
of communicating if you're in a pickle thank you they might
even be a little unconventional and if you're not quite up
to your adventure you can always just relax with your powers
enjoy the sunset dance the night away or steal something
from a friend and kick it into the You know, the usual
stuff.
You can also use mouse controls or hang out with friends
using cross-platform play.
After all, spending quality time together is the best part
of a big walk, strolling onto Nintendo Switch 2 August 4th.
Build your very own floating restaurant with the straw hat
crew.
Is this from the same dev?
Oh, it is.
They do a lot of collabs.
Well, it's because the games were all, the games that they
were shown were all announced before.
So I'm just like, all right.
I literally trust the guys.
I sat through at like four hours of gameplay showcases,
guys.
Like, at least like people were watching live.
They had at least a day to like, they had at least a day.
To like reset themselves.
I literally just watched these trailers.
No, I like their games.
I played the Doraemon version.
Over 400 characters from the One Piece series.
Or not the Doraemon.
It wasn't just Doraemon.
It was like everything created by them.
So like, they have a lot of crossovers.
So, I'm not surprised that they had a one-piece crossover
because they've done a lot of these.
Um, I know there's...
I'm trying to remember what the other ones were, but they
have a lot of different versions.
They're really well...
It's really well...
The Kari Soft is really well known for this.
Oh, hey, Pokapia.
Oh, it's DLC.
I will say not a lot of people are talking about the season
2 of One Piece.
five action first came out everybody was talking about it
but for season two i felt like i heard nothing about it
okopia plant grass build structures and expand your towns
underwater oh the pokemon is scheduled to release in august
2026.
that's cute is it free update the pokemon pokeopia expansion
pass paid dlc is on the way it's not a free Yes!
It's free!
It's a free!
Here's the expansion pass!
The Pokemon Pokopia expansion pass paid DLC will be
available later today on Nintendo eShop.
Part one of the paid DLC, Bubbly Basin, launches this bonus.
Okay, that one is free.
Part three will launch at a later date.
Look out for more details in the future.
Paid additional content.
Oh, yeah, it did a room.
Why if it's...
I feel like one won't be like a sky update.
Because, like, what else do you do after the ocean?
Maybe cave update?
A cave update and the...
Oh, hey.
See, that's...
Remember when people were complaining about how, like, they
didn't add all the Pokemon.
This is how they get you.
This is how...
Like, why do you think...
I think they didn't include all of them.
I feel like if you look at like how, like what Pokemon
they're missing, you can tell like which one would it be.
A prosperous land ruled by the gods.
The capital, Daxian, plays host to the heroic games.
The winner of which is granted one wish.
Powerful fighters from across the land have gathered to
participate.
Look, guys, more characters.
for the new Smash game.
Guys, they gotta make a new Fire Elblip game.
They're running out of characters for Smash.
Kai, a young boy determined to win the games to save his
cousin father.
Dietrich, a swordsman ever on the hunt for a stronger foe.
Theodora, a queen seeking to fulfill the long-held dream of
her homeland.
I'm sorry, I don't play Fire Elblip.
Smash Bros.
is like Nintendo's Bloodborne.
Or Silk Song.
It's Nintendo's Silk Song.
Sony has Blood...
Stata Play has Bloodborne.
Nintendo Direct has Smash.
And...
But to be fair, we lost Silk Song.
So what does...
the Game Award have.
What the Summer Game Fest or the Game Award have.
How you spend your free time is up to you.
Combat takes the form of turn-based tactical battles.
Consider your weapons- Half-Life 3.
And your unit's strengths on the battlefield.
Plus, each of the four main characters comes with their own
special techniques.
By using these techniques to the fullest, you might turn the
tide of battle.
Rejoice with me at the advent of the underworld.
Look upon the promised one.
Oh sorry.
The fate, the fire, sorry fire emblem trailer was still
going on.
To upheave the world
Be gone from us The darkest I feel like Fire Emblem is super
popular in Japan But I don't think it's that It's not that
popular in any right I know a lot some people really love
Fire Emblem But like it just doesn't have the same hype as
it does in Japan I know like Fire Emblem is like a top
selling It's like Top selling franchise in Japan, but not as
popular compared to Japan though
Welcome to the next level of ninja battles
Wait three houses made explode Oh, hey, it's Ninja la, yeah,
it's ninja la.
I never played ninja la one, but I know people say it was
fun accidentally breaking a forbidden seal your strand on an
uncharted planet it blew up with three houses and smash no
and smash people always complain about the fire and blood
carry if you like again yeah it's like the the you can also
blow a bubble it's like sort of like the splatoon but not
but what if they're ninjas instead of squids and kids
crafted from ninja gum you can even summon buddies with with
gum ninjutsu to unleash powerful attacks.
Additionally, up to four ninja can team up in local or
online multiplayer to chew through tough battles.
Oh shit, Monster Hunter Ninjata!
Uncharted Planet launches exclusively on the Nintendo Switch
2 system.
Yeah, I was gonna say this isn't multiplayer, this isn't PvP
anymore.
The DK Challenge barrels in.
Coming to Nintendo Switch Online on Nintendo Switch 2, The
limited time DK Challenge event.
Take on challenges across many Donkey Kong games available
with Nintendo Classics.
By completing them, you can earn and enjoy collectible
digital challenge cards.
And if you have Donkey Kong Bonanza, you can attempt even
more challenges.
Guys, oh my god.
I never played those games just seeing Donkey Kong turning
to a fucking a buff ass zebra play challenges and complete
your card collection competitive Donkey Kong Nintendo Switch
online app on the home menu of your Nintendo Switch 2 you'll
be able to I was not expecting the zebra at all that's a
buff ass zebra not gonna lie that's He pro was very buff.
DK Island and Emerald Rush paid DLC.
A limited time collaboration with Super Mario Brothers.
Super Mario.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
DK and Pauline.
Inspired by Mario and Luigi.
Okay, I was gonna say what?
Super Mushrooms.
Question blocks and more.
That's cute though.
Oh, like a collaborative.
Yeah, it's like a bomb.
meme where he gives himself a meta.
He's collabing with himself.
This is the one-time collaboration event.
We'll be held in four waves with the first wave beginning
later today.
It's like the greatest crossover of history within our own
company.
From the creators of Vampire Crawlers.
We played it.
Wait.
This is not Vampire.
Wait, JJK Vampire Survivors?
Survivor.
What?
Onto Nintendo Switch 2.
Up to eight players can compete online for the top spot in
this Survivor's Royale.
Competitive Vampire Survivors?
Don't battle directly.
Instead, take down enemies on your own map.
Just go Gojo.
Wait, they don't have Gojo.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Where's...
Is there actually no Gojo?
The match culminates in a head-to-head final battle between
the top two players.
Okay.
it who will be the final survivor i was gonna say just go go
joe isn't he op or is characters can be unlocked just by
playing battle online wait that's not fair let's play to win
computer-controlled opponents exercise curses dominate
rivals and rise to the top that's so random survival ton
launches on nintendo switch two that is so random i like how
it's exclusive random.
I did not expect that.
Brutal, unforgiving battle storm onto Nintendo Switch 2.
The fact that it's exclusive to the Switch 2.
Out of everything.
Defy the will of the gods to save what remains of humanity.
It's not?
Oh thank god, okay I want to try it.
I mean competitive vampire survivor?
Bro I'm like absolutely destroyed.
I do not have spreadsheets for this.
Like, I'm just playing a play.
A hero must rise for a god to fall.
Yeah, I feel like, I feel like competitive Empire Survivor.
This fall.
I feel like wouldn't it be like super RNG based too?
Like, oh, Pinocchio.
Oh, Pinocchio.
Yeah, I'm just thinking, like, wouldn't it be like, like,
How am I going to win in randomness in the roguelike feature
part?
Humanity.
Take on enemies using customizable weapons and prosthetic
arms that allow you to swap between different abilities.
But know this.
The lies you tell will alter your fate.
I like how they announced it.
It's coming on Steam, but yet they announced it on the
Nintendo Direct.
Complete Edition, which includes Overture, a prequel
expansion to the main game, launches on the Nintendo Switch
2 system.
I will say, okay, I'll let you guys know I know what the
final game release is.
I know what the final game showcase is.
It's similar to that.
Like, the fact that it's announced on Nintendo Direct
instead...
...plays Nero, Dante, like...
I'm just surprised.
...as you fight off hordes of demons and epic bosses.
Like, out of all these showcases.
Oh, it's not even...
It's not even the last game okay we'll see it then there's a
there's a game there that they announced specifically on the
nintendo direct instead of any of the other showcases
additional content so everyone was so confused because
everyone was like did not expect it in the nintendo direct
devil may cry 5 devil hunter edition launches on nintendo
switch 2 june 25th this is not even a switch exclusive
mystical era deep in Japan's past six souls determined to
forge their own destinies so you're looking for some runaway
ninja named Kisuke they still have some unfinished business
in this world I shall make him pay let's show what we
farmers have spirit you've sentenced me to die seven days
from now thanks to our repent if I were you an action RPG
for the ages I don't know the series, but I know that Ninja
Girl, because her figure is so poppy.
It was considered a grail at one point.
I like, like the pink Ninja Girl, her scale figure was
considered a, like a grail that people would, like, everyone
who had it because of how pretty it is.
With 4K resolution and TV mode, or full HD in handheld mode.
I remember because I would see it everywhere Everyone always
like Miramasa figure I'm trying to remember When you see it
you'd understand It was considered a grail figure Because
everyone was like Obsessed with this figure It's really
pretty I understand why It's a very pretty figure So like a
lot of people were trying to get it Back in the day It's
this one You might recognize it if you see it This figure
like recognize it.
It was super popular back then.
I didn't even know where it came from.
So I was like, oh, that's where it came from?
Yeah, I saw this figure everywhere.
And I didn't know what game it was for.
It was for.
And I knew there was a lot of bootlegs made of this figure
too.
Alright, back to So I was like, oh, what a sorry.
I was like, oh my gosh.
That's where it came from!
Not only that.
Oh, I saw I broke freaking out about it.
But you can travel on a high speed vehicle in the first
game.
Xenoblade!
Control blades to fight mercenary squad battles in the
second.
And put your strength to the test against waves of enemies
in the third.
There's also a variety of...
Now there's pot racing.
the three games.
More details will be revealed at a later date.
Yay, more content.
It's all free.
The digital version of Xenoblade Chronicles Definitive
Edition, Nintendo Switch 2 Edition, and the upgrade pack
will be available later today.
The physical version launches on July 30th.
What unquote free.
The Nintendo Switch 2 editions of Xenoblade Chronicles 2 and
Xenoblade Chronicles 3 will be available on the date shown
on screen.
It's so free!
Three Xenoblade Chronicles games are getting Nintendo Switch
2 editions.
New features will be added to each title, so we hope you'll
check them out.
And a new story in the Xenoblade series is about to be...
I saw people freaking out about this on my Twitter.
I'm not a Xenoblade player, so it's like...
But I did see the...
I did see everyone freaking out about it.
Yeah, so you'll play fans are very, very passionate.
Because it's a really good JRPG game, right?
It's like one of the best ones.
I assume like the story itself is like really, really good.
Because I mean, I mean JRPGs, you know?
I tried to play a JRPG game.
from level 5.
Is that a company?
Level 5?
From, you know, the company that gave us Professor Layden.
What was it?
Nino Kuni?
Is that Nino?
That's a game series, right?
Yeah.
From Nino Kuni?
I really did try because I love the artwork and the
animation style of level 5.
And I really tried, but I just couldn't.
I tried my best But I just was I even Nino Kuni I couldn't
get past I couldn't even I don't know
Yeah, it's the first Nino Kuni Yeah, it's the first Nino
Kuni
The very first one.
Xenoblade Genesis marks a new beginning.
What kind of story do you think will be told?
Please look forward to future updates.
Tennis!
Please take a look at this.
Welcome to Woohoo Island.
Home to all kinds of sports.
Come into Nintendo Switch.
unfortunate name.
I...
The what island?
The what?
The...
Or even handles.
You all guys, you want a good...
It's like the other island, you know?
It's like...
There are 12 sports to do.
All with intuitive motion controls.
Let's go over them.
It's like...
It could be like the other island.
...and outmaneuver for the knockout in boxing.
Not related to other islands, by the way.
In table tennis.
Oh, wait.
Is this...
Is this where he does the thing?
Enjoy rallies with different types of shots in tennis.
If I want to see if this is where we see it.
Yeah.
I saw the gifts, guys.
I don't know, we went to the wrong island.
Guys, that's why it's called Woohoo Island.
Then swing your club in golf.
I'd come back for now.
Oh, there it is.
And your opponent a defeat in thumb wrestling.
Ride through the course using mouse controls in
skateboarding.
Yeah, but I still want to see the hand motions.
Steer with handles and coast along the waves in power
cruising.
tilt the controller and fly around freely in prop plane
plus you can warm up for these sports with jump rope you can
create and play as a sportsmate or me character oh the me
character is fun I like that all right we're done with the
hand motions no one will stay on the right side Enjoy
playing all kinds of sports on Nintendo Switch 2.
This right side doki day.
This is the real highlight of the direct.
This is why we're all here.
Recorders begin later today on Nintendo eShop.
Nintendo Switch Sports Resort is coming to Nintendo Switch
2.
We showed all the sports included.
But since we have the opportunity, let's try one of the new
sports.
Dumb Wrestling.
Ah, yes, a real man's sport right here.
Pull down your opponent's thumb for three seconds.
Now, here we go.
I get to see it live.
Just take the controller to break free.
And if you keep your thumb held down, you'll get- Someone
should get a doctor.
I think their thumbs are- I think their hands are swollen.
That man's thumb is very swollen.
We gotta put someone find a doctor.
guys i don't think that hat is getting the blood flow guys i
think yeah i think the i think the the cause here we go
let's have a good match all right oh got him right away they
broke free i think i should cover this maybe i should cover
it oh we bought thumbs oh go go go hold it oh they broke
free again you have to keep them pinned very unfortunate
camera wait wait wait
i was worried for a second there he's very good with it okay
i'm starting to sparkle whoo hold on a second that's not how
it's supposed to go It's okay.
Everything is fine.
It's okay.
Next, he's covering me up the action.
Thank you for the bitties.
Thank you.
Now let's try.
Oh, I got deflected.
He got deflected.
Oh my God, he parried.
He did.
I lost.
The thumb parried.
Please wait a little longer for Nintendo Switch Sports
Resort.
Let's move on to more headlines.
That's what I'm saying.
I think covering it was even better.
To survive a land ruled by dragons.
The world of RuneScape comes to Nintendo Switch 2.
An ancient power has awakened on the forgotten continent of
Ashenfall.
I think everyone loses during that.
When the clarity hits.
And uncover lost secrets on your journey.
to face the Dragon Queen.
In this survival crafting adventure, delve into the
mysteries of Ashenfall, amongst the ruins of fallen
civilizations.
On your expedition, harness the land's transformative magic
to gather resources, craft gear, and build shelter.
Then, step into battle, forge weapons, sharpen your skills,
And face the danger that awaits.
Wait, the trailer's still going.
I don't understand some of the trailers sometimes.
It feels like...
It feels like some of the trailers go on much longer than I
think it will.
Get on board for these games.
Okay.
Oh, I saw this!
And play in the adorable world of Hello Kitty Party Land.
It's it's it's Sanrio party.
It's a Mario party And several board games We'll ruin
friendships with Sanrio characters Sanrio characters to meet
That's so cute We're gonna kill that guy What the fuck It's
actually suffocating I'm gonna suffocate you Finally a real
game Two days before or before right before before
Halloween.
So let's get down there and finish the job.
Oh shit, Star Fox!
Blast off for adventure across the Lilat system with Fox
McCloud and his crew.
I still thought it was really funny.
Japan was so hyped about the Star Fox designs and then
everyone and they were just like, why does he look like
that?
game's opening stages oh my god he's so cool
hope resonates within the crystals it was too furry for any
depends like this is not furry enough
get ready for the first final fantasy game in hd2d final
fantasy resonance this is lapis a vast world that has
prospered through the power of crystals but after the
invasion of the veritas this once thriving world lies on the
brink of annihilation now rain a night of grandchild that's
me across the realm with his oh it's a oh it was a mobile
game with gotcha man they must people feel silly right now
don't they don't you guys feel silly right now.
Can you uncover the truth behind the Veritas?
And the secrets the crystals hold.
Final Fantasy Resonance launches on the Nintendo Switch 2
and Nintendo Switch.
Yeah, but I meant like if you were one of those people that
spent a lot of money on the mobile gotcha.
Oh, that's where the the meme video came from.
adventure what do giant fruit malevolent robot frogs and an
all i always feel bad when like a gacha game shuts down and
then you know you don't keep your digital husbando wifus you
know the amount of like crystals you powered up with but
beneath this seemingly happy world lies a sinister plot to
squeeze the locals for all their worth time to join the
resistance abilities.
They live off forever if I receive.
It's worth a... I never played a game, but it's worth the
animation with the dancing one.
And in this sequel, navigate and explore in full 3D as you
discover the secrets of this vivid, colorful world.
Get ready to wander, solve, and gossip in Picuniku 2.
Yay!
switch to next year that's cute it's a cute game prepare for
what oh uh dragon quest is that monster filled adventure
that was called a slime game yeah it's the slime game two
girls find themselves lost in the kingdom of witherwood
the power to turn monsters into friends.
Dragon Quest Pokemans!
Oh my god, it's a full circle!
It's like Dragon Quest Builders!
Because Pokemon was like, I'm gonna steal your dev team who
made Dragon Quest and now they're like, well, I'm gonna
steal Pokemans!
Yeah, I know.
I heard like Pokemon based during the first Pokemon game
They took a lot of ideas.
They took a lot of ideas from Pokemon designs from the
original Dragon Quest game.
Take on the most fearsome of foes with a team that's
uniquely your own.
Yeah, if you look at like Pokemon designs versus Dragon
Quest designs or something, a lot of the original designs
for Pokemon, they took inspiration from Dragon Quest.
Let me see if I can find it.
About time you got here.
oh she looks looks a little bratty see let's see i can find
it let's see
upon the ancient sovereign's honor and
we are monsters each find
here oh we saw this trailer before i remember which one it
was which show there's so many showcases the dust Bloods.
Yeah.
We saw this before.
Not Bloodborne.
Yeah, it was like supposed to be a spiritual successor to
Bloodborne.
Was it a year ago?
I remember, I was like, oh, eh.
Same as devs, but then they put it on Nintendo.
More news about an upcoming treasure hunting game.
Oh, we saw this.
Hey everyone.
Here's some.
Are you guys okay guys?
Oh, wait, no, we did it.
Oh, shit, we did it.
Wait a minute.
I thought it was the raft zombies.
I thought it was a raft of forest because it was the raft.
It's platoon.
Sorry.
I literally saw the raft.
No.
Oh, she's cute.
We're using the hideout ship as their hub.
Hunting for treasure across these landmassives.
They're going to show raft zombies.
All right.
I'm the Splatoon fan!
I'm one of them.
There's a bunch of aggressive creatures called Salmonids in
the way.
Is this Splatoon extraction shooter?
Oh my god, even Splatoon is not safe.
The Salmonids aren't pushovers either.
So you shouldn't go anywhere.
That's crazy.
A Splatoon extraction shooter.
That's where this comes in.
The exploration bot.
pilots it during your treasure hunts and attacks
automatically launches you in the air for extra height i
love the splatoon designs they're so cool i have some of the
splatoon fashion outfits because they release like collab
you know that he used to release collaborations during
splatoon one and two i have some of the shirts like splatoon
official splatoon shirts that they made another that spins
ink around you and more and the best part not the ones
released by nintendo it's like official japan collabs with
like fashion brands and i had to like order i think i had to
i don't remember how i got i remember i had to order it like
special i didn't use a proxy there was a website for it for
people in asia because at that time i was living in asia so
i could like i don't have to use a proxy service you the
mechanic will also get stronger by leveling up and you can
customize all sorts of upgrades to fit your play style this
is a roguelike looks like time's up there are even more
details to cover in the upcoming Splatoon Raiders direct
airing on June 30th and in the smart device it looks a
little roguelike but I don't know I don't know the power-ups
are like set or yeah it felt like risk a raid I mean risk of
rain is roguelike a special splatfest in splatoon 3 the
theme looks like it's about splatoon raiders details will be
announced it looks like you're literally nintendo what do
you mean it looks like it does it is or it does it what do
you mean do you think they have inside sources Yes, yes.
So what did you think?
Splatoon Raiders is just around the corner.
We'll also be releasing new Joy-Con 2 controllers.
Oh, those are cute.
Let's see some more headlines.
That's what the sources say.
Could be.
We don't know for sure.
I'm like, what?
You're Nintendo.
It's your, oh, it's your game.
Oh, hey, it's the, yeah, Undertale dog.
Maybe I'll finally be able to play Delta Room, guys.
Maybe I'll finally be able to play Delta Room.
I don't remember.
Was I going to play Delta Room Chapter 1 or 2?
One?
I played Chapter 1.
I played Chapter 1 when it first came out.
When it dropped on Halloween.
Whosoever have truly earned the greatest faith of the
citizen or the new year.
I don't remember when the Delta room one came out It was
like a fucking shadow drop shit This is the United Kingdom
of Eukronia inhabited by eight tribes The next king shall be
decided by the will of the people by decree of the king as
his face floats in the sky The tournament for the throne
when did a shadow drop that as the realm grapples was it on
Halloween right?
Yeah, it was Halloween Remember the shout dropped it and I
played it on stream.
I played it on this channel You'll try I don't even know if
there's a clip that exists of it I don't even know someone
even clipped it various enemies by streamed it on this
channel, but I'm fucking gonna stream it fuck it Yeah, I
played I played it on this channel when it's got a shadow
drop known as humans Control your destiny so maybe some bark
night remembers Refantazio.
Launching on the Nintendo Switch 2 system.
No, we're talking about Delta Rune.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's lost media.
Explore.
Survive.
Oh hey, Minecraft.
Nintendo Switch 2 version of Minecraft is on the way.
Dig into your Minecraft adventure on Nintendo Switch 2 with
support for vibrant visuals.
I vaguely remember Chapter 1.
I just remembered the I remember the ending where she like
Wakes up and looks like looks evil so you can pick up right
where you left off What will you create next?
Minecraft launches on Nintendo switch 2 this year
All right, there are all the other games that you can play
on other consoles guys
The lightning round
Look at all these games.
Look at all these games that did not pay Nintendo enough to
show.
They're like, what can I give for $5?
It's true.
Or the shout out.
This is what you get for $5.
The $5 shout out.
you know it's
crazy switch despite it being a family friendly console uh
oh hey it's not animal crossing anyway you know it's crazy
that uh they have no that that is just not animal crossing
and harvest moon
Yeah, they do not have very good What's the word called?
Oh, hey, Kingdom Hearts.
There it is.
They don't have really good, like, checks and balances when
it comes to, like, the Nintendo games on the eShop.
Not very good, like, filtering system.
There's a lot of AI porn games there.
All sorts of magical allies.
enemies in action RPG combat relive these stories or
experience them for the first time there's one about feet I
saw it on Twitter people like tweeted about it if you have
the cloud versions on Nintendo Switch you can transfer your
existing save data to these Nintendo Switch 2 games these
three collections launch on Nintendo Switch 2 October 8th oh
there's a guy version and a girl version.
And it's like all AI too.
It's all, it's like visual novels and they're all made with
AI art.
Additionally, they do not have really good.
Oh, what's this?
What's Remind?
Oh, is Remind just like, you know, what is Remind?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, it had DLC?
I feel like a lot of people 3.
Kingdom Hearts 4.
What if Sora was in the real world now?
He woke up from his coma, guys.
Remember the Kingdom Hearts theory?
What if Sora was in a coma?
Wait!
Look, sir!
He was my favorite!
Oh my god, he's just as hot as he was.
Like, I can't believe he got even hotter.
I...
He was my...
He was literally my favorite organization member!
Like, everyone would be, like, what's it called?
It's a guitar.
Like, look, I don't even remember the other members.
It was, like, the guitar guy.
Like, others would talk about, like, Zigbar, guitar man.
And, bro, Luxor was my favorite.
and also I also hated him because like I was stuck on his
boss fight for 20 years I swear I did not understand how to
kill him I remember I loved him and I hated him I forgot I
didn't read the I guess I didn't read oh yeah Axel I or like
you know it would be like the demix or whatever or Axel But
my favorite organization member was fucking Luxor.
Oh my god, he looks so hot.
Wait, I'm sorry.
Let me What time I need
That that's my moment that was my my favorite part in
Nintendo direct You don't understand he was like nobody.
Oh my god He's He was my favorite I Oh my god He's so HD now
He's so He was He was my favorite organization member
Someone was like You remember his name A fucking course I
remember his name A fucking Of course.
I wish there was more out of him.
I really like oh my god that look
There is I know don't worry.
I know People would ship him with zing bar
But he was my favorite Also, he's a gamba.
He's he's all in and gambling But yeah, no that guy.
I remember the first time I played Kingdom Hearts 2, I rage
quit because I couldn't beat him, because I didn't fucking,
you know, I didn't read.
I was not good at instruction, with instructions, and so it
was only later on as I got older, I replayed Kingdom Hearts
2, and I finally was able to get past like Luxor's, Luxor's
fucking level, because I realized what the rules were.
I didn't understand, I didn't understand the rules because I
had really bad comprehension.
He was still my favorite.
So, like, I would play that level over and over and over
again.
Long ago, there was a land called Hyrule created by beings
of supreme divinity.
That's my look, sir.
That's my favorite organization member.
Fuck Roxas, Axel Demix, or whatever.
Fuck the Twinks, bro.
Look, sir, that's a real member.
That's a real organization.
member right there.
That guy was hot.
These forest dwellers are called the Kokiri.
Each had a fairy companion, and they lived out their
innocent lives in these woods.
However, there was one particular boy.
I am like his, like, you know how like, like each
organization member has at least one fan?
I'm that one fan that looks rude.
that it's like all the others will have like millions of
fans i'll be the out it's fine he's like you know what's it
called like every pokemon like has at least one fan every
organization member has at least one fan
it's like what you have rare oh shit oh oh fuck ocarina of
time
Sorry, I was too busy thinking about Luxor before I realized
The legend Zelda Ocarina of Time will be reborn on Nintendo
Switch 2 I'm surprised I'm not surprised I feel like
Twilight Princess deserves a remix more I feel like Ocarina
of Time That's all for today's Nintendo Direct Has got
ported to a lot But like I feel like Twilight Princess
hasn't Hasn't got a port yet right With a few words from
Devonson first thank you for watching oh it had a port
yeah i know but ocarino time it had a lot of love like i'm
devon pritchard and yeah on the wiki though one of my
favorite things about gaming was an ocarino time on got
ported to the switch i watch the trailers i hear about a
game but the moment i pick up a controller that's when it
all comes together and for me that's oh it was on a 3ds
those little moments that me and allow me to emerge ah i see
you can watch a trailer but nothing beats seeing it for
yourself is this are we at the treehouse now part of what
nintendo treehouse live oh we're on the treehouse now all
right we're done i would like to have twilight princess i i
feel like twilight not because of what's your name minerva
or whatever not because of or the wolf i i know everybody's
like always because of the wolf or or i guess oh minda sorry
Alright, it started with an M.
Like I said, I've never played Zelda before.
The only Zelda game I played was the Train 1.
And obviously, everyone said that was the worst game you
have ever started on.
But, like, I've never played any of the Zelda games before.
But I would love to track and green all the time.
Anyways, we did it.
We watched five hours of showcases.
But we caught up now, guys.
Yeah, I didn't even play Breath of the Wild.
We did it, guys.
We finally caught up.
we did it I'm gonna call it here everybody thank you
everyone for hanging out with me today I had a great time
chilling with you guys doing a watch along catching up on
all the latest news I renewed my gamer license I'm finally
all caught up now but thank you everybody for hanging out
today we guys had a fun time watching along with me though
you guys have already you guys some of you guys might
already know like all the games that were coming out or i've
already seen all the trends but i haven't but now i have now
i'm caught up i'm i'm back in it guys i'm not hip with the
kids again um for those who don't know me my name is
dokeybird and i usually stream on youtube so please check me
out there because that's where my main channel is like i
said i do like the fun like the extra fun stuff here on
twitch so if i do want I do like guerrilla streams or like
spontaneous streams or watch a lot of stuff.
I'll be here.
You want to know whenever I stream on Twitch?
Please follow me on Twitter.
Exclamation point Twitter, socials or anything.
Please follow me there for updates on whatever I stream on
Twitch.
You want to support me by other means.
I have a lot of stuff you can do.
There's the gamer subs code.
There's the Fortnite code.
There's merch.
Exclamation point merch.
And all of that.
Great way to support me.
And I do have a content.
That's come.
That's in two weeks, guys.
I'm so looking forward to seeing all these guys at the
concert.
Yeah, I'm so excited.
It's only within two weeks.
Anyway, guys, I'm gonna call here.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, pause, check it out,
and move around to get that blood flowing.
And you said, for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm watching longed out now.
Bye-bye, everyone.
Bye-bye.
I don't know if I'm raining or not, so we'll see if I have
no rain.
I'll let you guys know in chat.
So I guess stay a little bit until I say disperse.
Bye, guys.